e e
welcome to
Edna I'm this is this is the committee
orientation and I'll
be um asking you all to introduce your
yourselves so we can know all know the
proper names and the proper
pronunciations which is always a fun
issue ah yes nearly everybody's here
that now representative I'm Carol
Maguire I'm the chair and it in my ninth
term in the house and my fifth term is
the chair of
Edna
um so I I have set ways of doing things
I hope you will accommodate
them which when we have we have hearings
we're
um I I try to do them in a timely
controlled manner I we do do ask
questions but I would ask you to keep
your questions focused on the
bill there's a we have topics that
people don't know a lot about and so
I've arranged
for um orientation with the jail car
staff on Ru making with the retirement
system and with the office of
professional licensure which deals with
licensing and those are the three main
areas we deal with so please ask all the
questions you can think of about to
those people because they they will know
what the the system answer is and
they'll help you to to learn about it um
what
else uh on minor points I don't object
to uh having computers I've got one
myself just make your make sure that
you're respectful to the people
testifying
so um and let's see there's a coffee pot
in the office you're welcome to use it
if you're going to be a regular then
either give me some money or
um bring in supplies your choice if
you're just going to get a cup once in a
while don't don't sweat the small
stuff representative Pearson has a bill
in the Senate so he'll be coming back
after that uh representative de breze if
you'd introduce
yourself here we go Erica de Hampton
Hampton all right and why are you on
Edna cuz I was assigned to
it all right
honesty Fred Davis uh from nashar uh
this is my second uh term on Edna so
it's nice to meet you
all glinton Bailey from Milton I also
represent Rochester W five and I'm
returning
Jeremy slashy I represent
Hudson Peter Schmidt U I represent
doward one this is my 23rd
year hi my name is Heath Howard I
represent straford and barington uh this
is my first term on Edna and my second
term in the
house I'm John sitech from Salem I was
assigned to Edna when I won a special
election a long time ago it's the best
Committee in the
House John is also our
clerk Erica Leon from Derry it's my
third term in the house first term in
adna hi everyone I'm Jackie groda this
is my fourth term in the house and my
fourth term on Edna and I agree with
representative scitec that it is the
best committee and I find that this
committee works well together because we
um have bills that are uh that relate to
agencies and administration is something
that we should all be um supporting and
I look forward to hearing your ideas on
them thank
you hi my name is representative James
TBO I'm from Franklin representing
Franklin in Northfield my first term in
the house and um this is an area of law
I'm not as familiar with so I'm looking
forward to learning with all of
you good morning morning I'm
representative Vanessa Shen um this is
my third term in the house I represent
the town of Milford this is my second
committee um my first committee is ledge
admin where I serve as Vice chair my
first time on Edna and I'm looking
forward to learning uh even more thank
you hi I'm Paul dargy from Milford uh
this is my second term in the house uh
first term on
Edna representative John SOS from
Bristol I represent Bristol and brid
water up by the Lakes Region and this is
my uh I was assigned to this Committee
in my second
term
okay all right one uh one minor thing to
take care of the commission on
post-traumatic stress disorder in First
Responders H it needs a uh member from
Edna this is a nice introduction to
statutory committees because it's met
twice in the past year so it's not a lot
of work is there anyone who's
interested oh you are interested
excellent I will make a note to uh
recommend your name to the
speaker
okay
[Music]
and my fast
I'm sorry I thought that introducing
ourselves would take a little longer so
I scheduled an hour
um obviously we're in good shape to make
our uh three minute speeches so I have
other prepared remarks oh well thank you
John that's
excellent uh a lot of the work we do is
in
subcommittee and since the committee is
smaller this year we're down to three
subcommittees there's the pension
subcommittee which representative Lon is
chair of the licensing subcommittee
which representative Pearson is chair of
and then representative Sheen has other
which at the moment looks like it will
be the State Building Code because we've
got four or five bills on it and at
least one will probably go to
subcommittee if you um there's a list of
subcommittee members and the office if
you have very strong objections let me
know or find somebody to trade places
with uh I try to assign them based on
your interests as much as I knew of
them so we yeah Jackie so I do have I
thought maybe we might elaborate a
little bit on the state building codes
because we're not having an orientation
on that and um I'm not sure if everybody
is aware of what the state building
codes signify and what they represent
present and I think that
um it's something that um
historically we have uh well on my first
term it was a it was a big uh it was a
big issue because we hadn't adopted the
um we hadn't adopted the latest building
codes I think my first ter was it was
2019 and I don't I think we were
reviewing the 2016 building codes but we
hadn't adopted them since
2013 was it had been quite a while so as
a result of that this committee made a
commitment to itself that we would
always stay current with the building
codes but we would not adopt the newest
building codes we would adopt the
previous ones because the um those
building codes can some can sometimes
have bugs in them you know like little
things that you don't expect so it gives
us a um it gives us codes that are Curr
but have been reviewed by
other um towns who may have adopted the
building codes so the if I remember if
I'm correct about this towns have to
adopt the building the ad the the ones
that we um the state the legislature
adopts however nothing prevents them
from going beyond the current ones so if
they want to adopt the newer ones they
can yes right we yes that's General
generally true we made some changes this
past year when we adopted the 2021 codes
for the most part
um we changed that towns that wish to
make amendments to the building code
have to do so formally by a vote of
their um I think it's the legisl I think
it's their governing body so the board
of Selectmen can vote to adopt a change
to the building code but they have to
send it into the State Building Code
Review Board in order and which will
publish it so people know the idea of
the state building code is that it's a
State Building Code and every town and
City should be using the same code with
possibly some minor changes there are
places in the codes where you have
options you know you can do it A or B
and some towns decided Well we really
like be better so we'd like to have the
local option to do it that way which is
reasonably
legitimate but the difficulty has been
that many municipalities were not
formally adopting their code changes and
were not publishing them so a lot of
people that were trying to build were
surprised when the inspector said oh
that doesn't meet the town Coast you
can't do it that way you've got to fix
it and there are
allegations that some inspectors were
making it up as they went
along which I which I believe may have
happened I'm not don't know any that
happened to me deliberately but there
were enough comments of that sort that I
believe that it has happened so we're
trying to make it easier to build in
that you know what the rules are before
you go
in
and um and and I'm a me I last term was
a member of the building code review
board liaison committee which met with
the building code review board which is
a uh a panel of experts there are no
legislators on it there are Architects
and Engineers plumber and electricians
and home builders commercial
Builders and Architects I think oh yeah
definitely Architects so they know the
building codes they use them and they're
the ones
that provide us the State Building Code
but we have to ratify
it and this so this year we
have uh at least four bills on the
building code
and ex officio I'm sponsored of at least
one of them which consolidates all the
enforcement materials about the building
code which had been scattered through
the town authorities and the city
authorities and the Fire Marshals
Authority and put it in one place with
the building code so that it
um you you could go and see who is
enforcing it in your
town um if anyone in uh my town we have
a zoning compliance officer who checks
for the location of the driveway
clearance around the
well uh proper position of the septic
system and that's about it he doesn't
inspect the house that we built for for
Code
Compliance so um and that is not
uncommon in small towns in fact having a
compliance officer that actually checks
well clearances and septics system
location is better than
some uh what else so that's the
consolidation Bill we have a bill
uh from that will update the state
energy
code
uh which was not updated when we did the
rest of the building code we have a bill
to restrict Municipal adoption of
building code
changes and then there's a fourth bill
that I don't remember at the moment but
we'll be hearing all of
them oh and update the electrical code
yes thank you that's on a different
cycle so we we will be having all of
those bills heard on the same day and
I'll leave time on at least one of them
for people to get their questions out
about the codes and the
processes the thing about building codes
is that
there's they have two different types
first is they tell you how to build
safely and how to and in particular the
updates tell you how to use new
materials and processes because the
original building code we had was for
say was for stick build houses as time
went on it developed how to
use pre-built presses which is a
different building Style but so we
that's covered in the current codes um
and then there
are um manufactor specific requirements
that keep getting thrown in and in some
cases the building code goes from M you
know manufacturer A's materials to
manufacturer B's materials back and
forth when really they ought to be
alternates because they're both both
safe and effective but you do you deal
with the materials differently
any any contractors plumbers or
electricians in the
group okay well darn I'm no but I was an
architecture minor and I love this stuff
okay
excellent yeah I'm I'm a mechanical
engineer by training so I that's how I
got stuck with it Edna got it some years
ago uh because we had on the on the
committee a representative who was a
master plumber and a master electrician
so he really knew what was going on with
the codes and he was basically the lead
for the whole house for um as long as he
was kept getting
elected yeah I just wanted to add that
building codes are a rather animated
subject so that we will get a lot of
testimony on those because they're
integral in our everyday life right and
um often time it's I we would I would I
support a Statewide building code
because I would want houses that are
built in you know let's say the town of
Franklin or Milford to be as safe as
those that we build
elsewhere so um I think and it's also
good for people who are buying houses
because if they have an inspection one
of the things the inspector will look
for is whether or not the house is code
compliant so it's good for the owners to
know that we have State Building
Code yeah okay John thank you a question
on that how does that apply to
properties that have houses that have
already been built and for 50 100 150
years there is
a uh
existing building building code that
directs how you um
update if as long as you don't make any
major changes to house it's your
business but if you've got 1940s and 50s
electrical circuits I recommend you
change them just for your own safety um
the in fact as long as you keep owning
it there's no problem if you sell the
house the new I don't know if you make M
changes though there you will have to in
some cases bring parts of the house up
to
compliance and for commercial buildings
it's it's also somewhat more ex
extensive and that's that's an issue
that keeps coming up over and over
again represent
Schmid thank you madam chair may I speak
to the uh subject of administrative
rules and the jail car since especially
since we're going to be talking with
some of their people at 11 o'clock yep
please uh please do representative
Schmidt is the longest serving member of
jail
car uh that's true this will be my 19th
year on the jail car um I was put there
uh and here simultaneously by former
speaker Teran nelli because there's a
lot of overlap between a Jael car and um
and Edna that's one of the things I
think you'll all enjoy and profit from
is that we have a lot to do with uh
state agencies and and state rules and
so forth and we will see a lot of the
top people there one of them is with us
this morning to speak to us at some
point Allison is on by your HHS right by
Department of Health and Human Services
um jelar stands for joint legislative
committee on administrative rues rules
uh and um many statutes require kind of
instruction manual on how they are to be
implemented and those are called
administrative rules and uh the
legislature gives up a portion of its
power to the um to the various different
state agencies in order to oversee uh
those specific areas such as Health and
Human Services uh and um in order to
make sure that the agency is staying
within its powers the rules that it
devises for implementing statutes have
to go through the jail car for approval
um and there are three members of this
committee who are currently on the jail
car
representative Maguire is the just uh
previous chair of the jail car uh as a
member of the House there are five house
members and five senate members on the
Jael car um and It Go the chair goes
back and forth between the the two
Chambers representative Maguire was the
chair in the previous term from the from
the house and now it's the Senate's term
and so repres Senator Lang is the chair
at this particular time the chair of the
jail car is chosen by the members uh
elected from either the senate or the
house um and um so and also
representative Gro is on the on the
currently on the Jael car along with me
representative Leon representative
Maguire and um so th this term and the
name will come up very frequently on
administrative rule issues so um it's an
advantage to this committee to have
several members who understand the
process quite well uh and um and
therefore they can help the other
members of the committee to understand
more easily and speak to that from point
of experience we also have a couple of
members on the joint committee on
on classification on committee on
um I'm blanking on it the joint
committee on employee classification
employee classification thank you I'm
used to calling it
JCC um two members of the jccr by
Statute from this committee one Democrat
and one Republican and I'm currently on
the JCC as well from the Democratic side
and um the previous Republican member
didn't get reelected so we were going to
have to appoint somebody some republican
from this committee by Statute will have
to be on there the former um member was
represented scitec when he was on this
committee but he wasn't on this
committee last term so he couldn't be on
continue on the jce because it has to be
two members from Edna one Democrat one
Republican so I'm hoping representa
scitec will come back because he's the
longest serving member of
JCC um now that Senator de dallesandro
has retired after 15 50 years in the in
the what he means is I keep the
[Laughter]
minutes yes thank you we will have a
bill on jce later I think it's couple of
weeks out
so um that's something I want wanted to
mention about schedu
oh first I want to introduce Mr Bradley
Greenland who is our committee
researcher he will provide a lot of data
on some of the things we're working on
when we get into Senate amendments and
Committees of conference he'll give us
comparisons of the different versions of
the bill
uh and he's very helpful in a lot of
other
things uh so we'll be we we'll be seeing
a lot of him he keep he keeps track of
what we're
doing in a helpful sort of
way okay what
else oh yes scheduling that was what I
was going to talk about we have at the
moment 36 bills up 30 from Friday so uh
we just got three yesterday afternoon
and they are all early bills those are
bills that go from us to to the house
and then on to a second committee we
have to be through with them by March
6th uh so I'm doing my best to schedu
schedule all the bills particularly the
early ones up front so we can
take we can take some time off um next
week I've scheduled two days of six
hearings each and
probably weeks after that we we meet on
Wednesdays and
Thursdays uh we don't need a Corum for
public hearings so if you need to or you
have other conflict
feel free to skip them they're all
televised so you can catch up if you
need to
um on and as a warning on February
12th I'm scheduling uh some lighter
bills we have
a state animated film which we will be
showing immediately after lunch when we
and then considering the bill that um
that goes that recommends it as a state
film we have the state a new state flag
design we have a committee on flag
design and
um and Daniel Webster day plus another
bill on General
holidays um they're all on that day um
if you want to go skiing that's one I'd
recommend it's it's they're all very
uh very light in fact I've invited
fourth graders from from one of my towns
to come talk to us about the flag
because in my opinion their judgment of
the flag quality is at least as good as
mine and may be
better excuse
me other than that I'm waiting till we
get more bills at the moment the speaker
said there's something like 200 more
bills
that haven't been written and assigned
to committees so and looking at them it
looks like the tough ones are the ones
that are coming out last and they're
more likely to be early bills so the
week after next we'll I'll schedule all
the early bills there's a couple of uh I
think two or three pension bills and
some controversial licensing bills so
next week we'll be tougher that the week
after
next sorry what else yes you represent a
B has the flag we saw it last year it's
unfortunate that they've got a mirror
image of the old man
but nobody's
perfect yes I just wanted to um remind
the committee that early bill means that
the bill will be heard by two committees
typically the initial
committee is the has to have it which in
many cases well not in many cases but
every every policy committee is going to
have early bills and in our case many of
the early bills that we have will go to
finance after but some of some of them
go to a separate committee maybe HHS or
um Commerce me ways and means so you
know if we so all committees who have
bills that are going to be heard by two
committees have to go through their
bills by the certain date and those
dates are on a calendar if you start
reading the the calendar and look at
that section where they have the dates
those dates start to make more sense the
more you get involved with committee
work no and we will be getting some
second committee bills if there's a bill
from another policy committee that deals
with Ru making or licensing we'll get it
as a second committee to look at that
that issue
um not as many as we used to but
there'll be
some yeah the deadline for early bills
as I said is March 6 so we'll be trying
to get those out
uh a my policy has always been to get to
vote out as many bills as we can so um
except for tomorrow where I forgot when
we're in hearings if there's a bill that
we hear and everybody in the committee
looks at each other and say well that's
a
loser we can immediately vote to get rid
of it or contrarywise we say well duh we
should have done that years ago the same
thing so I will hope to get a lot of the
easy
bills quickly out of our possession the
harder ones go to
subcommittee um and the subcommittee
chairs can
schedule as many meetings as they want
when they want uh some subcommittees
like to eat meet first thing in the
morning because I won't start the
committee before
10 and other subcommittees like to meet
afterwards or on other days of the week
you know it's it's up to the the
subcommittee to figure out what works
for them and how many meetings they need
to
have
generally the bills sponsors and
sometimes the agency or their Lobby of
the supporters will work with the
subcommittee to make sure that we meet
their intent and
um most of the time a subcommittee will
recommend ought to pass with Amendment
and I've had to apologize to the house
at least twice for reporting a bill as
ought to pass with amendment when we
actually didn't amend it because I was
so unused to the idea of not having an
amendment
I do want to add that subcommittee
meetings are public hearings so that the
chairs of those subcommittees will
notice those meetings um so you'll get
they'll be in the calendar but you'll
also get the notification from
our uh Robin Robin what's her she's a
commit the only difference is that
subcommittees only need 24hour notice
so that it's perfectly possible at after
the hearing the subcommittee chair will
think how about we meet tomorrow at 9:00
and that's or actually at 3 o'clock and
that's that's good
enough um but they will be posted they
are public you will have people here
yeah so you have to be here yeah
yeah representative sellers thank you is
will you be having any uh executive
session on the same day of as
hearings yes like I said I expect to do
the obvious ones right away and there
are there are
some and there are others where it looks
obvious going in and then
the some of the testimony makes you say
oh my God we never thought about that
and we we send it to subcommittee uh it
it depends on the
circumstances uh
and I will confess that I forgot to
announce executive session for the bills
we will be hearing tomorrow afternoon so
some of those might be taken up next
week if we have
time there's at least one that I think
we will decide we'll agree we want to
pass it immediately but I've been wrong
before but I am scheduling
a an executive session for for our um in
weeks toward the end of the month and
that will be bills that uh weren't quite
so obvious but we've worked through and
that one will or they've gone to
subcommittee and the subcommittee was
easy
um so we'll we'll do
that I'm trying to think of all the in
the things that might happen and there
could be that if we decide to exec a
bill and some of the committee members
are unsure about their position on the
bill it's possible for someone to ask um
for a caucus so that the Democrats and
the Republicans can e caucus before the
executive session it's highly unlikely
that we do that on bills that we decide
to exec the time because as chair
Maguire had says it's typically bills
that are um obvious when we hear the
bill and we can tell by the tenor in the
committee and the questions that people
are on the same
page
yeah yeah and speaking of that if I
please subcommittee chairs do not
schedule a uh the caucus is the
executive session I think is starting at
11: please do not schedule a
subcommittee at 10: because we want a
caucus we will we'll have a first caucus
so people can get used to the idea
she you at
something yeah uh Edna is fortunate that
we don't get a whole lot of partisan
issues but there's always a few and
there's some that that come out of
nowhere and you realize that without
planning all the Republicans are on one
side and the Democrats are on the other
side my uh first term that
happened because we had a second
committee bill that dealt with
providing Energy Information to home
buyers which was perfectly fine except
that it wanted
to have the real estate
inspectors prepare data on it and
provide the information and we the
Republicans all said well
you the home inspectors aren't
responsible for that kind of information
why should their license fees go toward
this other task
and so we ended up with a purely
partisan issue on a very straightforward
bill that we disagreed on how it should
be
implemented first time I spoke on the
floor that's why I remember it so well
all right any other uh questions
comments
no repr say so for those of us who are
just getting used to the calendar should
we plan on being here Wednesdays and
Thursdays for the remainder of this
month uh yes thank you yes after after
January
um we probably will will back off quite
a
bit
um but the really tough bills will still
be in subcommittee so that that will be
the main effort is working through the
the the difficult bills
so what did I forget to
mention all right well I don't want to
talk anymore repr L on yes um yes did
you speak about the copies of the bills
and how we'll get those and that process
in order to have a hard copy as well
well as the electronic and how to access
the electronics all right our first for
hard copies we have a committee
assistant Robin Bach who sits outside of
Commerce 301 she will be providing us
hard copies of all the bills assigned to
the committee at the moment they aren't
all done ah this is Representative Steve
Pearson
sen
here yes the building double booking yep
and um so anyway we will get hard copies
of all of the bills assigned some of
them will be later than others but
expect to have them the ones that we're
dealing with at the time of the hearing
if not sooner you'll you will be getting
a set of them uh there are drawers in
the committee room that are
um one one of them will be assigned to
you the labels aren't up yet so uh sorry
about that we will have to take care of
it and that you can keep whatever you
want in
there we don't recommend
food all right
and yes and I always schedule plan to
take a lunch break because I need one
and I assume many of you will as well uh
so we'll you'll have time to to at least
get up and stretch and go for a walk and
maybe you can get something to eat
um yes represent Pearson if you want to
introduce yourself we'll be
sure so I am uh Representative Steve
Pearson I'm a four-term rep out of dairy
I've got 27 years in the fire service I
work for the city of Manchester as a
lieutenant on the West
Side
um I have um I live in East da so I
enjoy the benefits of living in our
fourth largest community and also kind
of in the woods at the same time which
is
great I have some interesting
hobbies and uh
beyond that I'm for those of you that
don't know me you
will I am uh not afraid to hold my
tongue I will assert positions that I
think are
important um I have served on this
committee before I did two terms here
uh and I despite you know a little bit
of the heavy workload that we do here I
do very much enjoy uh what we do here at
Edna I'm happy to see representative
scitech back certainly and after after
his Hiatus as well and uh I think that
uh you know
we'll we'll have a good two years here
and we'll accomplish some great things
for the state
so
um I am certainly open to suggestions
I'm certainly open to questions uh I'll
talk with anybody about anything so
beyond that um please try to refrain
from having a medical emergency take
your meds please uh I'm tired of dealing
with that in this building
but well actually it it looks I mean
there some years we had four or five
paramedics on the committee we have yeah
so this year it's all I think you're the
only one that that's fine that's fine
believe me I uh no problem there it's
it's been on the other hand the
committee looks younger and healthier
than in many other years so yeah yeah
we're doing yeah we got a good yeah we
got a good group here we'll be all right
I mean I'm not saying we should extend
lunch and I'll go to the gym together
but um I do appreciate you madam
chairman mentioning lunch that has some
committees have a problem with that they
run too long that's just it's not good
for any of us so um representative
Schmidt you've got a I just want to note
for the other members that uh
representative Pearson is one of the
group of a small but distinguished group
of people who are part of a family unit
in this in this body his father is also
a State Rep and a chairman of family
law correct children of family family
law he's in his fifth term yep yes and
I'll mention that my husband is also
serving in the legislature he's on both
finance
and uh Educational Funding so I've made
an arrangement to meet him after the
budget passes that passes the house
because I not going to be seeing much of
him in the meantime so if I refer to Dan
without any other reference it's
probably my
husband yeah one particularly fine year
we had members of four different married
couples serving on Edna which was
a an an interesting
situation all right nobody else has
anything questions
comments she's represent Howard yeah uh
so I just wanted to let everybody know
uh we have online uh remote testimony
missions uh that I'm going to just read
out numbers uh whenever we have hearings
uh just so that people are aware thank
you thank you very much for that I that
came in Fairly recently and so I was
mostly ignoring it but that's not the
right thing to do so thank you very much
for your service that that will be
helpful represent Pearson I just have a
question on the online stuff do we have
origin of uh online testimony as far as
CU during the co era uh with several of
us that have served during the co era um
one of the things that got a little
tiresome for me was listening to the
opinion of people in Oregon and Utah and
Wyoming because they had the ability to
just pipe on um the internet and
and interject themselves into a New
Hampshire process that is really
designed for New Hampshire citizens so
yeah there there you uh are required to
enter which town and state you live in
okay that's that's great because I
because I the weight of that certainly
matters to me so yeah well fortunately
we're not doing hybrid Zoom meetings so
they can still
submit testimony through the portal or
in writing to us in any way they like
and but it's only the people who come
and actually talk to us that we'll be
able will'll be excuse me able to
interact with yeah I just wanted to
clarify I'm only reading out the number
uh not every single person and in the
general text that they submit along
inside that uh testimony yeah because of
nothing else the um the online testimony
is probably like the email you'll find
out that on any Hot Topic where hot is
in the eye of the beholder you will get
a whole bunch of form emails which are
identical and my policy is unless
they're from my town I'm going to ignore
it um read one and then toss the rest if
you actually get a a personal
testimony that's you know they're
thinking about it that's worth a lot
more than just checking off a box and
sending a form email as I'm sure you
will all find out when we get to some of
the Hot
Topics represents schmi I mean you're
you're going to see very frequently it's
uh 50 or 100 emails that are identical
so they they just all their only
contribution is if they sign it all is
it a different name but it's the same
email over and over and over again so
that's obviously an organized effort to
influence us and I think it doesn't work
in my epic yeah speaking of that I hope
you all have a uh an email box for
public use that was that you can handle
receiving large quantities of emails
because you will be getting them and you
don't want to lose something from your
brother-in-law saying we're we're coming
over on Sunday or whatever in the midst
of that nor do you want the email that
your spouse sent you up subject to a 91a
request as well precisely you want to
keep it for for public
things anybody
else may maybe you've noticed
representative Pearson the chair and I
are all speaking quite closely into the
microphone um because uh you will see
some of the Witnesses are a foot away
they might as well be speaking into
their hand uh because the microphones
are sensitive but not to a voice from a
foot away so you can speak calmly and
with without any great volume if you
have the microphone very close and and
another thing is you'll notice that most
of us are turning the microphone off
when we're done because if multiple
microphones are on the level of fidelity
to the voice goes way down so you really
need the chair will keep hers on because
she's running the meeting but uh it's
good idea to turn it off when you're not
using it
okay so I have a question about how what
your discretion will be regarding um the
public reading their
testimony if it's really a member of the
public they they can do it if it's a
lobbyist or a professional I prefer that
they just give us the highlights because
if you've seen a bit of testimony you
know that somebody reading their
testimony is much less persuasive than
somebody using their testimony to to
give remind them of the highlights and
actually talking to us and I hope and I
certainly don't want I would encourage
people not to read their
testimony that's I'm not going to gabble
down of an actual citizen
any yes represents CCH if I may about
reading I encourage them to I would
encourage them to read it because you
know it's going to be over somebody
speaking extemporaneously will just go
on and oh my God and Abraham began ISAC
and no no no I just representative zitec
has a lot of experience particularly
since he's been clerk many times and
uh that's a Viewpoint I hadn't
considered or delay on you have
something uh yes for the members of the
public it's just a matter of what makes
you more comfortable if you're reading
through and you can be concise that way
that's wonderful if that stresses you
out just speak with
us so all right and I will do do my best
to make sure all of our new members get
the opportunity
to get an amendment to write a committee
report and speak on the floor because
that's something that's it's not that
horrible please you don't have to start
out with a with a speech on a major
issue we have the advantage that most of
our our bills are inside baseball
they're small they're about things
people don't know about you can actually
change people's minds with a speech if
you're talking about a licensing is or a
rul making issue God forbid nobody comes
in with preconceptions about rule making
if you want to speak on a gun control
Bill
say you're speaking to posterity in the
in the journal because everybody knows
what they think about gun control Bills
going into the into the
session
um
so we we we'll invite everybody to make
a to write a committee report and if
necessary speak on the floor about some
minor issue they care about you don't
call them blurbs
anymore our clerk Mr Smith
is thinks blurbs are is an undignified
term fine as oldtimers still call them
that so if I ask you for your blurbs
that's what I mean it's the committee
report and uh speaking of that I take
them written or email to me and uh I
have
a because of my experience working on a
newspaper I frequently edit them for uh
grammar coherence and so forth so I'll I
will gen I will
normally send them back to you for
approval for uh before sending them on
so in that case I think we're about done
everybody gets a chance to stretch their
legs for 10 minutes since it's been
noticed we can't start early
that's yeah yes sorry the the rule is
you can you can start late you can't
start early so 10
minutes
e
e e
good morning the gabbles are on order so
I won't have one for a
bit we have here a presentation on the
rul making process from please introduce
yourself good morning uh my name is
Douglas ster how I am the director of
the administrative rules unit for the
office of legislative services and with
me is one of the committee attorneys
Rebecca Ricard if you've ever attended a
Jael car you probably recognize Rebecca
um until recently I was on the wrong
side of things I was at this table
during Jael car but I sit over there
where representative Davis is now um so
uh representative Maguire asked us to
put on this presentation we're going to
keep it relatively short it should be
about an hour with time for questions uh
we're going to do kind of a high level
overview just sort of the relationship
between legislation and rules and sort
of what that means um it's nice to see
some of you again uh representative
Pearson you were on Edna when I first
started coming here every single day
over the last few years a lot of new
faces as well so uh we'll get started
this is us the office of legislative
Services we did hand out paper copies
and representative scitec I sent you an
email there's an electronic version and
I half apologize to attorney rard that
uh I didn't have
time it's the same exact doc so there is
an electronic version coming to you as
well so I thought we could start right
at the very beginning um the
constitution of the State of New
Hampshire uh small potatoes so the
there's a couple of different
administrative procedure act models out
there there's one from the 50s there's
one from the 80s and there's one from
1992 I believe New Hampshire's model
after the 1980 APA and that uh so what
you'll see is there's a very nice
opinion of the justices that came out in
1981 that I referenced quite a bit in
the beginning here and they you know the
ultimately legislature has the supreme
power to draft
legislation The Authority lies with them
um but they do also have the ability to
delegate that authority to the executive
branch and so I'm just citing throughout
here you can go uh the executive branch
has no no inherent rule making Authority
so when you're like a commissioner of an
agency it is your job to make sure that
agency runs dayto day but they don't
have any inherent Authority in the
agency to Draft rules or promulgate
rules of any kind um the legis ler may
not delegate unlimited Ru making
authority to an agency so you can't
completely turn over the Reigns U not
that I've seen that happen or from what
I've gathered nobody really wants to see
that happen uh which is a good thing
some checks and balances and then an
agency's authority allows it to sort of
fill in the details to effectuate the
purpose of the statute and I'll get into
some examples later on too as to what
that
means uh I'll leave time for questions
at the end but also if you have any
questions feel free to stop me a lot of
people in this room know I contend to
ramble uh so we talk about the
delegation of power I've already
mentioned the APA but in agency is
defined in RSA
541a um
APA as I'm going to actually read this
definition each state board commission
Department institution officer or any
other state official or group other than
the legislature or the courts authorized
by law to make rules or to determine
contested cases now that seems like a
very simple thing and maybe too simple
for this but I have had to come before
the legislature on more than one
occasion and argue that definition of
agency to a committee never house Edna
thankfully uh but but other committees
um but what an agency can look like
varies very very greatly so I put a
couple of examples on here on one end
you've got Department of Health and
Human Services which has multiple
locations thousands and thousands of
employees The Authority is granted to
the department but individual programs
and are going to be promulgating the
rules and drafting those rules now the
commissioner has to have eyes on they
have to sign off on that but it's it's a
very different structure than other
agencies uh a good example is office of
professional licenser and
certification uh so everyone knows prior
to this position I was General Counsel
for the oplc and prior to that I was in
the Bureau of General Council for Health
and Human Services so I've been in a
couple of state agencies oplc is an
interesting one it's a much smaller
agency and then you're going to see
different typ types of organiz organized
just organized differently over there so
you're going to have uh for example the
Board of Medicine which is its own state
agency that works sort of hand inhand
with the oplc and you're going to see
advisory boards such as recreational
therapists who are even though they're a
professional board it's the office that
has final rul making Authority for that
board so even though it's two boards
within the same agency the structure is
going to be very different depending on
who you're talking about and then
there's uh the office of the right to
know on budsman a personal favorite of
mine that is an agency of one it is Tom
Kerr he is the only employee of that
agency he sits in the basement of the
annex he's a delightful individual if
you ever get a chance to meet him uh so
you'll see on one end you've got HHS
with thousands of employees and then
you've got the right to know on budsman
an agency of
one uh this was supposed to be deleted
uh so I also want to go over real quick
what a rule is because this is very very
important so a rule is any regulation
standard it's a statement of General
applicability uh meant to implement
interpret or make specific a statute
that prescribes or interprets agency
policy or practice and I bolded this
piece because it's key binding on
Persons outside of the agencies
including other
agencies so so internal practices and
procedures right we have this column
over here what a rule is not so internal
agency me memoranda or policy only
applicable to employees so if you're
looking at a license the the
requirements for the license might be in
rule how that license is processed when
it comes into the agency might be a
policy or in a procedural manner for the
agency not necessarily a rule though it
could
be uh information pamphlets letters are
explanatory material you'll see a lot of
this at HHS uh just explaining their
programs uh personal Personnel records
relating to hiring dismissal promotion
compensation investigations discipline
that is not rules although There are
rules that govern sort of how the state
treats its own employees those are the
Personnel rules and then if it gets to
this point the Personnel appeals board
his sort of administrative rules for
hearings about employees and then
declaratory rulings uh you're not going
to have to deal with those too much in
the legislative branch at least as far
as um statutes and that's basically when
somebody's confused about how a board or
an agency would apply rules they can
present the facts to the agency and said
if this was a case before
you how what what would the outcome be
they're not binding and they're very
specific to the individual and the facts
before them it's not really a big part
of rules right now uh so it is Cle I
just want to keep that binding on
Persons outside the agency including
other
agencies so why is this important
because rules once properly adopted
carry the force of law now if they ever
conflict with a statute the statute is
going to Trump we'll get into that more
a little bit later but rules do carry
the force of Law and they are binding on
the citizens and the agencies uh oh look
at that that's what I was going to say
one comment I want to put in is that
normal rules expire in 10
years and an expired rule cannot be
enforced and that is a policy that we
put in some years back but it's very
important because there are some
activities that are only defined in Rule
and there are also things like fees that
are defined only in rule the the law may
say you may have fees on about this but
the specific if the specific amount of
the fee is set in the rule it can't be
collected if the rule has expired
and we and jail car have been beating up
a number of agencies about enforcing
expired rules and I personally intend to
do
so absolutely so when I say a rule is is
binding on an agency I do mean any rule
that is only properly adopted through
the system and still still in effect so
as representative Maguire explains rules
do have expiration
dates so there are also I earlier I
mentioned that there the the legislature
cannot delegate all of its rule making
authority to the executive branch but
there are other limitations on rule
making Authority both on the legislature
but also on the executive branch so uh
this one is applies to an agency an
agency may not delegate its rule making
authority to anyone other than the
agency named in the statute delegating
Authority so I can't if
I'm I think oplc is a good example so if
you have the office and you have the
we'll use the Board of Medicine again
they both have different roles and
responsibilities the Board of Medicine
could not turn over that authority to
the office because it's easier or more
convenient or faster for them they have
the obligation and they have to do that
rule making um the other an agency may
not adopt rules other under another
agency's Authority and that can come
into play when you see transfers so I'm
going to keep jumping back to HHS
and oplc quite a bit because I'm very
familiar with both agencies but for
example the Board of Nursing used to be
housed under Health and Human Services
they're now uh housed under the oplc so
if there was any roles and
responsibilities that would have been
the agencies being HHS those would now
have to fall under oplc and that's going
to require a statutory change uh one of
the things um Edna has been working on
and you're going to see a little bit of
it this year is um just sort of clean up
statuto language to address those kind
of things uh nothing like the last two
years
though uh other rule Mak limitations on
rulemaking Authority even when there is
General delegation of Authority there
are certain requirements and rules that
need specific statutory authorization so
a good example of General delegation
Authority uh would be such organ
organizational and procedural rules
necessary for the implementation of the
statute or for the office that type of
language but even with that language in
place without specific language in the
statute an agency cannot promulgate
rules around penalties or fines license
or licensing and that includes layers of
licenses within licenses uh fees
non-consensual
inspections uh the expansion or
limitation of the scope of who may
practice a profession or submission of
social security numbers and you will
sometimes see in statutes when it comes
to uh limitation on scope of who may
practice a profession the statute will
also will sometimes explicitly say you
have have no rul making authority to do
that it's just so that it's very clear
um not entirely entirely necessary
because if it's not explicit The
Authority doesn't exist but I think it's
it's very helpful for people on the
other end you may jump in and just
another example with regard to the fees
so if the legislature wants to set a
specific fee for something for example
for a license you need to put that
directly in your statute if you want the
agency to set the fee say you know they
need to make a certain amount of money
in order to operate like a lot of the
boards at the oplc then you can give
that agency the discretion to make the
fee so that's something you think about
when you're making legislation do you
want to set a fee and have that fee be
the fee or are you going to give that
discretion to the
agency yeah within within limits of
course if you say that to a fine no more
than
,000 most agencies will consider that to
be a floor of
$1,000 so you'll you'll expect just to
narrow down that fee pretty precisely
and the other is that it's a good idea
to put uh limitations on what how much
the fees can be even if you're giving
them the authority so that you would say
to collect the fees to fund the
operation
plus no more than 25%
extra uh that's because you're
estimating the the for the
future you you can't do it exactly so
you you want to aim to have the fee
cover it plus a little bit um this ver
BR I just wanted to make a comment to
the committee that one of the reasons
why this is important is it's often
times people we submit bills and after
their past we're like phew glad that's
over but really there's a whole
component afterwards which is the ru
making component that lately hasn't been
as um the details to that attention
hasn't been paid so I think that's why
this is particularly important to our
committee because we do see um bills
that come to State agencies will talk
about the ru making of the agency and I
think it's something that we should sus
out when we hear the bills and that
that's something that if you choose to
serve on a different committee we hope
that you'll take with you and you will
look at the ru making Authority on other
bills and say okay yeah that this is too
broad like we had um just before
Christmas we had a bill about not a bill
a rule for approval about
landfills and I went and looked at the
authority the agency had to
design this the technical scope of the
landfill and there there were no
technical criteria whatsoever none zero
so they they could they could make up a
number it it said you have to consider
you know the environment around and but
how closely around in what matter no no
details they figured it out and we've
gotten a lot of I've I've lost a lot of
fights on the house floor saying we're
giving them too much Authority we have
to make a decision about
this but other people didn't want to
belly up and say no we we know what this
number should be or what the scope of
this issue is and we want the DS to or
HHS or whomever to take care of
it yes representative
Schmidt thank you uh Madam chair uh so
in in line with what you have just been
talking about one of the things that you
have been very instrumental LA and in
your time in the legislature in this
committee is uh addressing the issue
that uh that your language I think was
very not only appropriate but but kind
of illustrative of the concept that that
you've just been speaking about that
so-called barnor situation where the the
statute says the commissioner shall
write rules that's it which meant that
uh and and that that we had a lot of
rules like that where the commissioner
had blanket Authority and uh and agency
really in many cases does not like that
because it exposes them entirely
whatever the commissioner comes up with
uh is now the is now the law and uh
because rules is you've been saying Doug
uh has a force of law um and now the
commissioner has created a whole
structure based on that blanket
Authority well uh it's an invitation to
overreach and so we've been un undoing a
lot of situations where it's not that
blanket because if it is that way we're
stuck with that uh but to get the rule
making much more specific along in the
lines of what you've been talking about
so that they do not have blanket
Authority
um and no barn doors but uh it's
important for the committee to
understand that as well thank you that
was one of the accomplishments of the
20112 legislature representative Schmidt
and I put in the requirements for a lot
of cases of broad rulemaking Authority
including the entire State Medicaid
Program which had been under the
commissioner of
hhs's blanket authority to implement the
pur purpose of this chapter but we we
the two of us and with a help from other
committee members wrote the requirements
for
the Medicaid Program what the agency had
the authority to do and I'm actually
very proud of that
accomplishment all right thank you for
the
interruption well I think this were some
very excellent points and I think it's
also good to point out as you've done
representative Maguire that even when
you give the agencies Authority it's not
all or nothing you can set parameters
around that and then also that list on
the previous page there if you intend an
agency to say be able to collect fees or
a social security number because of an
application you might have to put that
in there and so so that sort of General
language might not get the job done
excuse
me um and in in addition to the
limitations that are in statute there's
also limitations on rule making
Authority in the Jael car rules
themselves and just real quickly there's
um I I mentioned this before but
statutory Authority is needed to create
categories or level of a license or fee
system um though if there is Authority
for fees fees may be charged for
different Services uh Authority needed
for subpoena power uh there's
been talk about Department of Education
and their subpoena power for the last
few years and that keeps coming up over
and over uh they would need the
statutory authority to issue a subpoena
um to require continuing education for
professional licenses however if a
committee gives a board we'll use Board
of Medicine again authority to set the
requirements for uh renewal of that
license they can set education
requirements as part of the renewal so
that's that's kind of a splitting hairs
thing that you'd have to take a look at
each and each and every time um
liability insurance for lies and then uh
it also it adds a little bit more to the
prohibition on collecting Social
Security numbers and creates an
exemption for purposes of preventing
criminal acts such as fraud or to
identify tax or criminal
records and then I mentioned this
earlier but even though rules carry the
force of law they are not law and they
if they conflict with a statute the
statute is going to Trump the rule every
single time and then specific
authorization is required to incorporate
any reference by code rule or document
from another state government uh a good
example of that is uh State Board of
Education and they have the ability to
promate rules for recertification of
teachers but they can also do that based
on another State's procedures if or
other states professional development if
it's approved by the New Hampshire
Department of Education so that would be
an example of specific statut language
allowing Department of Education to use
another State's criteria if
approved um more limitations on Ru
making Authority this is a big one I
used the picture Boston party it's in a
mood administrative rules are subject to
the prohibition against unfunded State
mandates to political subdivisions and
this is something that agencies have to
attest to every single time they
promulgate a rule uh they are not
allowed to increase the costs for
political subdivisions to
rule the uh the ex
blanket exemption to that is if the
municipality has freely
adopted a program say a transfer station
or whatever then by that act and funding
it they are cons considered to consent
to minor minor changes to the
requirements
so that's the biggest loophole we've got
yeah there's a there's a couple of cases
I think the most recent and maybe
impactful is that city of conquer case
and they to do talk about in that case
um sort of like if it's a new roll of
responsibility if it should be the rle
of responsibility of the municipality
and they gave it up to the state and are
not required to take it back um if
there's just a changing in funding so
there's a lot that goes on that analysis
but that's a constitutional question uh
not going to get into it too much
today Pearson you've got a well yeah
there's another thing too with 28a in
the S of in the sense of consent right
so if a if a if a political subdivision
agrees to do
something then the 28a
procedure is now different so that is
where uh there needs to be uh some
discretion when those that are willing
to consent to something um or enter into
something at the state
level now have to understand that once
they've consented to be part of that
whatever it is that they've now can't
turn around and go whoa whoa hold on 28a
28a well wait a minute you've consented
to be part of this and 28a is out the
window and we have multiple court cases
to affirm the fact that that is how
things go so so it's just a word of
caution for those that that jump into
something that don't think about the
fact that you've surrendered some
safeguards uh when it comes to
[Music]
28a and then
uh yes and then um on top of the
requirements prescribed by the
legislature for the agencies to adopt
there's also blanket Lang language that
requires agencies to adopt which you'll
typically see in rules the 100s the 200s
those chapters uh organizational rules
those are your 100s those contain your
purpose statements those types of things
and rules for practice and procedure
tend to be in your 200s that's where
you're going to see
your
um disciplinary proceedings your
adjudicative proceedings appeals you're
going to see the ru making process laid
out in in those 200s you're going to see
waiver language for the rules in those
200s and uh important thing to point
point out too is in the 100s and 200s do
not expire other rules expire after 10
years the 100s and 200s do not expire
unless something happens either to the
agency or there's a change but they can
be in effect essentially in
perpetuity uh and then again waivers any
agency May wave its own rule but they
must have a procedure in place in rule
about how that is done and again those
are going to pop up in your 200s most of
the time
so then once uh a bill is passed it's
signed by the governor it goes into
effect and then it becomes the agency's
responsibility to actually promate the
rules and those procedures for the
adoptions of rules is governed by is uh
RSA 541 A5 through A14 that's sort of
for regular Ru making and then there's
additional requirements there can be
emergency rules there can be interum
rules that are in play only for a short
time there are a lot of moving parts to
this but in general once the legislative
branch has given the authority to the
Executive Branch the executive branch
now has the obligation to bring those
rules
forward uh it's a very simple process
that looks something like
this so uh we're actually on Friday
going to be giving another presentation
specifically to the Jael car and that's
going to have a little bit more detail
on on the the rule writing process
specifically I thought for today since
you're going to be creating the law is
giving that Authority that would be the
focus uh it is a little bit of a
complicated process there's a lot of
moving Parts there's actually six
different types of rule making that can
occur um each with their own sort of
different deadlines and standards and
requirements that have to be met um but
for your basic basic rule you can
simplify it down to essentially these
five steps and remember there's a
million moving Parts in each of these
steps but essentially an agency is going
to file um with OS that's us the initial
proposal of the rules they intend to
adopt and that includes a fiscal impact
statement a fiscal impact statement is
sort of
the impact of the rule would have on
costs either to other agencies or to
lenes or whoever they might be in the
public or or a change in rule or if the
rule had been expired and they're going
to be um prolongated again a new you
could compare it to the old rule uh the
LBA does the fiscal impact statements
and they provide them to us uh agency is
required to hold a public hearing and
they receive comment on public
testimony um then after that the agency
modifies the rules based on stakeholder
input that can look very different I
have had rules where I've had a 100
people show up and we've taken testimony
for hours and hours at these public
hearings I've seen public testimony in
the hundreds where you've had to distill
it down down to 100 Pages where you
might have duplicative testimony and
I've had public hearings where
absolutely nobody shows up and I wait
around for half an hour and then I put a
note to the Jael car that nobody nobody
came um then after the agency has
modified the rules they submit a final
proposal uh they might need an
additional fiscal impact statement if
there's significant change to the rules
and then that final present uh proposal
is what is presented to the Jael car
The Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules made up of both
members of the house and members of the
Senate I'd like to comment that the when
they are preparing the initial proposal
is the most that's the most useful time
to comment every week you will receive
an email notice of the rul making
register which lists the pro proposals
that are starting that are in the
process at that stage stage and it tells
you why they're doing the rule and the
text of the rule and the why the rule
also includes how to comment and who to
comment to when the public hearing is
and what the period for written
testimony
is uh if you would open that up and look
at it there may be some rules you know
from your previous
life uh if you're a real estate agent
saying you you've got rules on the from
the real estate board you would should
look at it if you've built a house you
should look at things
about uh the plumbers board or
whatever take a take a look at it or you
know if you are not an expert you may
just send a general comment or what I
found useful is send it to some friends
who really do know the
subject I I've got a couple of
contractors I've dealt with and I send
them everything that might possibly deal
with that and because they the the
trouble with most of the analysis of the
rules is that we all aren't in the gut
in the dirt we don't understand the
details something that looks perfectly
fine on
paper may get all the actual people
involved in a screaming fury because
it's
outrageous and you won't know it unless
you're familiar with it so spread that
to u to more people that you know and
ask them to comment and the written
written comment is ju is nearly as good
as going to the public hearing as Doug
said lots of times nobody shows up or
it's it's at An Inconvenient time but
they do pay attention to public comment
so please do okay I think that's an
excellent point and the other thing an
agency can do and I know I have done
this in the past when I was with the
executive branch is actually put out a
notice that says we are going to submit
an initial proposal and solicit that
feedback and see if you can get Buy in
before you ever even start with a formal
rul making process it can be very very
helpful especially especially when
you're looking for subject matter
experts the other thing is when a an
initial proposal comes in that comes
along with a public notice and one thing
that OS Rebecca myself will do is we
will rev that notice to make sure it's
sufficient but it has to identify the
specific statutory Authority that gives
the agency rulle making Authority it has
to identify the specific statutes that
the rules are intended to implement
because that might be different from the
rulemaking authority itself uh and it
has to give in enough it has to give
enough detail so that the public when
they saw that notice is going to know
what's going on when the agency is doing
new rulem and if it doesn't meet those
requirements we will kick it back to the
agency and we will not put it in the
register until they sort of get their
ducks in a
row so once it's
gone
what
Schmidt thank you uh I wanted to ask you
to weigh in a little bit one of the
issues that we have come across in this
committee uh over the years is with
regard to pharmacies especially
compounding pharmacies I don't think I
don't know whether we have one operating
in New Hampshire right now I believe we
do but but but I'm not familiar with how
many in in the specifics but anyway some
of us who've been around for a while or
members of the public who are paying
attention probably remember the
situation down in Massachusetts about 10
years ago with a um one of the
compounding pharmacies that was uh
guilty of pretty gross neglect of their
requirements and so forth and they did
put some stuff together that I think
they killed a couple of people as a
matter of fact with some of the stuff
that came out uh and they got they got
shut down this was about 10 years ago
but to the degree that we have
compounding pharmacies obviously they
have to be under the the purview of the
state government to inspect them on a
regular basis and so forth make sure
that they're are not guilty of the the
kind of uh incompetence or negligence
that they were doing at this in New
England I think it was called something
like that when that wound up harming the
public general public and uh so we
that's something that we all need to be
aware of with regard to com compounding
pharmacies but also generally so maybe
you want to comment on that
well I don't I I don't know if I can
speak specifically to the compounding
but I do think it go it goes back to
sort of the delegation of power there
and then if you're going to give an
agency the authority
to promate rules around compounding and
and Facilities that can do that uh you
also need to it may be a good idea I
can't say need maybe a good idea to
include some sort of inspection
requirements right there in the statue
if you remember one of those uh
prohibitions on rulle making without
explicit Authority is the ability of an
agency to just go into a place so you do
need you do need specific statutory
authority to inspect without um the
other side's consent so that's an
excellent point well there's a modern
kind a relatively new kind of drug
that's out there called
biologics okay and there are three three
ways that those can be administered the
most expensive one uh and most
restrictive is at in the hospital itself
and most of our hos big hospitals have a
have a compounding pharmacy section uh
in there on their premises but that is
expensive and uh uh so many hospitals
have a a secondary facility that has to
be like 300 yards away or something like
like that otherwise they fall under the
billing requirements of the hospital uh
so there you you possibly have a
relative or or or a loved one that has
uh getting some kind of
infusions and they typically will go to
a such a separate facility
representative Schmid this is really
fascinating but it's kind of straying
from the topic well but I'm I had to
give you a little bit of background and
the the Third Way is some people of
course are very immobile and can't get
anywhere and those people they going to
have a nurse that comes to their
premises and sets up their sterile area
and so forth so they are they require
special training to be able to do that
and our this committee had a bill a
couple of years ago where we had a
subcommittee where we um so that's the
kind of thing that we I think we have to
be aware of if you have a relative
has that kind of need that that
capability exists but it's very
carefully restricted to people with
special training so thank
you I think that's an excellent point
too and I think it goes back to really
the necessity of subject matter expence
right so we're here at OS we we have a
bunch of Staff attorneys but if you put
a pharmacy rule in front of us we may be
able to tell you here's the statutory
Authority here's the um stat is going to
implement but we might not have the
pharmaceutical expertise so when you're
drafting that language you know speak to
your constituents your stakeholders get
that subject matter expertise both
before and after rule making has begun
um but once the rule making is complete
and that final proposal has been
submitted then it goes to Jael car for
review and the Jael car's primary Duty
excuse
me is to review proposed and uh
previously adopted rules that's gel car
rule 102.3 all the stuff here today is
available on the Gen website and if uh
that slide that said resources that was
supposed to be deleted it was too long
we can reach out I have cards with me
today and I can help people find
whatever they need um but pursuant to
541a the APA this is again a very
simplified version there's different
versions of approvals there's different
versions of objections but essentially
it comes down to the Jael car May
approve the rule and then an agency May
adopt um they may object to the rule an
agency may
still adopt a rule over Jael car's
objection and you'll see it says
presumptive validity and no presumptive
validity and the difference there is
that if the Jael car approves the rule
and the agency adopts and the agency
gets sued the rule is presumed valid in
court if the jail car objects and the
agency adopts over that jail car the
burden switches and the agency now has
to demonstrate that it is a valid rule
they do not have that presumption
anymore and then the other thing the jel
car can do and this will prevent an
agency from adopting is to introduce a
joint legislation essentially um a bill
that's going to change the statutes uh
and there's all sorts of timelines and
rules about when that has to happen
whether they're in session whether
you're out of session those kind of
things but it's it's way too specific
and complicated for the purposes of
today uh we also haven't seen one of
those in a few years at this point yes
but they that's
the point is that a committee cannot
take on the full function of the whole
legislature so gel car can approve and
it's assumed that everybody else in the
legislature who would have commented
agrees with the the committee but to
stop the rule the jel car has to get the
approval and agreement of the rest of
the legislature and I think I've seen
four of
them luckily I've never had that happen
to me me so um so the Jael car review
and I I think representative Maguire you
just touched on this a little bit but
Jael car is not a policy committee and
so they're not really reviewing the rule
for whether they think it's good or it's
bad they're really reviewing the rule
for whether it falls with in line with
the statute and if they have the
authority and that's we have recently
seen rules where representative Lon made
a speech specifically about this um a
jail car or two ago um but the jail car
does have ground to object to a rule if
it's proposed one if it's beyond the
authority of the agency these are the
types of things that OS staff are trying
to identify in flag for members of the
Jael car uh if it's contrary to the
intent of the legislature conflicts with
statute that doesn't necessarily mean um
the statute is trying to implement uh we
just saw potentially in the dental rules
last Jael car where the language in the
proposed rule conflicted with the
statute not listed in noticed because it
wasn't trying to implement that statute
now that's not necessarily going to
catch every time which is why subject
matter experts are so important um and
we we had a lot of public testimony on
that um if it's determined not to be in
the public interest that could be the
agency didn't necessarily take into
account public testimony but it could
also be things like Clarity if it's if
if it's ambiguous language or if if
there's an inability to apply the langu
language uniformally among the people it
falls under uh if it's deemed by the
committee to not have a or to have a
substantial economic impact not
recognized in the fiscal impact
statement that's again um a fiscal
impact caused by the rule and not
necessarily the statute um and that's
where where if rules change between the
IP and FP stage we might require an
agency to go back out and get another
fiscal impact statement from the LBA and
then for interm rules which is another
special kind of rule if the rule doesn't
meet the requirements to implement the
rule in term rules have I believe five
categories five Cate some number of
categories limited number of categories
for which you can do um an interm rule
one you might see is if the rule
expired um rather to shorten the time
where an agency is without a rule they
might do an in uh interm rule or if
there's a legislative change it's just a
quicker little temporary because an
interm rule only last 180 days not 10
years so it's sort of a quick fix
Band-Aid while you work on regular rul
making and then um after final action by
the Jael car be it um approval be it
objection the assuming there's no
blanking on the term joint resolution uh
the agency May adopt a rule the rules
will go into effect at 12:01 the day
following the filing with the ol un uh
unless they specifically identify
another effective date in their adoption
letter most rules again are valid for 10
years there are exceptions such as
emergency and interum rules and then
again it needs to be stressed uh adopted
rules carry the weight of Law and are
binding on the persons they
affect so there just a few things to
just think about we've kind of touched
upon a lot of them today when you're
drafting leg legislation things to keep
in mind is the language clear enough
that the agency will understand the
intent uh we talked about drafting
language with specificity but you can
also sort of finagle things so you can
have given agencies sort of General
Powers but within a very narrow scope a
good example might be appeals you might
say the agency can promulgate rules to
to do whatever they need to do to have
this appeal process work but so that's
very broad language but with a very
limited scope so when you're drafting
legislation you know this as well as I
do it's more more art than science but
but you have to be careful is it is it
specific enough also to avoid unintended
consequences you may accidentally cut an
agency off at the knees and not allow
them to do something that you intended
them to be able to do or the other way
you never intended an agency to promate
a rule of a certain kind but the plain
language gives them that Authority and
so that might require a legislative
change sometimes we don't figure those
things out until um till it's a jel car
and we identify that one of the things
we will do at OLS staff too is make
recommendations if we find say
conflicting statutes we'll do a you know
statutory
analysis whole bunch of work goes into
that but we might make the
recommendation for a legislative change
down the road uh is the Le is the
legislation going to impact currently
existing
rules excuse me uh will the legislation
require an agency to write new or amend
existing rules uh are you transferring
power or authority and that's another
one which agency will have rulemaking
authority again um I'm using oplc as an
example because it's it's
really one of the more nuanced that I've
seen I'll use that
term uh but you have like the oplc
versus the Prof Professional Licensing
boards and when I used to have to
testify on behalf of the oplc sort of my
tagline was you know oplc controls the
process the boards control the criteria
so the oplc might control how an
application is submitted I'll use the
Board of Medicine as an example again
they might set the criteria for what it
takes to be licensed as a doctor in the
state and then there's an interesting
One
28421 V which is a child support and
it's got HHS components and it's got
Lottery Commission components and it's
essentially if someone is out of
compliance with paying child support HHS
can notify Lottery lot loty can take
lottery winnings and redirect them um
it's an interesting statute to read
because it's buried in the lottery
statute but it also has HHS rulemaking
components so that's the kind of
thing you know it might be difficult for
a new HHS attorney to know that even
exists so just sort of thinking about
that SPS uh parsing it out to really
make sure roles and responsibilities are
clear
um is helpful is helpful on both sides I
think both for the agency and then the
Jael car when those rules are brought
forward uh so that's just quick who we
are we're a very small team there's
myself the director um Christina munz
who will be at doing the presentation at
Jael car on Friday is our senior
Attorney Kim Rebecca our committee
attorney Scott Eaton is the former
director two directors ago he does some
part-time work for us and then and we
have some administrative staff who takes
care of publishing the agendas the
Registries doing proofings for rules
those types of things um Danielle and
Cheryl uh so a small small little group
and um we work well together and we'll
get things
done so we've got couple minutes left we
shot for an hour we're right around
there course say your
name it's at the top top of that page I
know I know the old standby uh I can
spell it too uh
osterhout osterhout Oster yes sir I say
o t you know pronounced exactly like
it's spelled except for the silent
letters um that show crushed for a while
and then I I think I overused it and
committee members who would heard it so
I had to lay off but now that we've got
some new members on committees I'm going
to roll it back out for a little thank
you for the break yeah all right are
there any
questions all right one of the um
reasons to have us have this briefing is
not just to learn a little bit about
something that's not in most people's uh
experience but also to meet the people
and know the faces and you can always
consult with them if you're writing a uh
a bill or working on a bill with rul
making Authority they will be very glad
to help you because the better the the
legislation the easier it is for
everybody in will
making thank yeah a question I have is
if you're creating a bill and you don't
actually mention
rules can rules still be
added normally not yeah I was gonna say
no typically not it the the statute
would specifically have to reference
rules under 541a that's the L which we
look for to see if they have rle making
auor Authority and um as mentioned
before also specifying who has that rle
making Authority um if neither of those
are present then it's assumed that the
no rules can be made under that statute
oh you just have to be careful because
if you're sticking a paragraph in a
section that has rule making Authority
at the top for the whole section it you
might have it there
but just think about it and I think
that's an excellent point because
sometimes with rul making Authority
you'll look at say Board of medicines
Practice Act they will have a section
that specifically says rulemaking
Authority it will have a list but
sometimes in bills rule making Authority
is carved out it's not put in that rule
making Authority Section it's down in
other language so we kind of have to go
digging for it uh but the agency should
be flagging it for us when those notices
come in because if they we have to track
it down and we won't let that notice go
through if if they don't have the
Authority I do also want to point out I
have some business cards so if anybody
wants to take one before I leave so you
can reach out to us represent Schmidt
has a question thank you madam chair and
just for the committee's uh uh knowledge
the this committee constitutes one of
the pools of potential appointees to the
Jael car because at some point some some
of us will be gone um and therefore uh
Replacements typically are drawn from
Edan a uh to because we have uh five
regular members from the house but also
four or five alternates and they're
almost always from
Edna yes and we use the alternates to
see if they like it and if they're able
to deal with the process so if you
survive being an alternate then you are
very likely to be appointed to Jael car
and I've noticed that once you've been
appointed to Jael car it's very
difficult to get off so watch it watch
for it
guys yes so if a statute comes forward
that would repeal a certain agency's
rule making Authority in a certain
regard um would the existing rules in
place be repealed as well so it sort of
depends a few things could happen one
the statute could include uh address the
rul making Authority and the rules
specifically I've seen that before where
it says the rules are in place until
such and such happens at which time
they're no longer valid and then I
believe there's also if say Authority
switches from one agency to another
there's a one-year natural expor
expiration after that so the rules
there's enough time a window sort of to
keep them open so we're not completely
without rules but um they're not going
to last forever so it kind of makes sure
the agency takes action but it is
something to consider when when you make
maybe restructure agencies or do those
kinds of things what's going to happen
to the rul making Authority who's going
to have it what's going to happen to the
existing rules uh and representative
Maguire actually shared the language
that we used at oplc um to capture just
that kind of thing when some of the
authority was transferred from the
boards to the office yes the if you are
doing something like that you if you
don't specifically address what to
happen to the rules you can assume
whatever you like least will
happen represent p well thank you madam
chair just to jump up on that a little
bit if you were to remove the ru making
Authority from an agency would now the
entire way they operate fall under the
requirements of the legislature to come
up with because they don't have the
ability to do it
themselves if the agency doesn't have
the rulemaking authority it's probably
advised for the legislature to put that
in statute yes
all right any other questions all right
thank you and uh we the committee will
resume at 1:00
with sorry
1:30 for a uh presentation by the
retirement system and another question
and answer period thank
you
e
e e
all right good
afternoon welcome to Edna and uh please
introduce yourself and uh we'll see what
we can
do thank you very much Madam chair my
name is Jan Goodwin I'm the the
executive director of
nhrs um we want to thank you for the
opportunity to come here and present
this information to you I'd like to
introduce my staff who are with me today
um on my right is Marie Mullen
our our Chief Financial Officer and to
my left is um our chief investment
officer rald LEC Al are their names in
here no they aren't
our clerk would very much having
that and probably the rest of us too
because we may need to uh speak with you
in the future go through your names and
titles again gladly um my apologies for
not including that we'll be sure to
include that the next time my name is
Jan Goodwin I'm the executive
director to my right is Marie Mullen and
hs's chief financial
officer and to my left is rald LC and
HRS is re re rald yes r a y n a l
d and his last name is l l v e q u e are
you sure there's no s's in there I am
positive all right and he it's not
purely the French spelling okay and what
is what's his title he's our chief
investment
officer so he's the really important
person
here thank you I'm done my
interruptions we're a little bit silly
because it was lunch
few okay you're feeling your outs well
we're here um please stop us at any time
if you have any other questions also in
the audience is Diana kryon from our
legal staff she's our hearing officer
she's here um at an educational
opportunity to see what happens at house
Edna so I should warn you that we have a
large number of new members so that
there may may be more questions than
usual well we will do our best to um
answer all of them and if we don't have
the answer to a question you're posing
we will get back to you as soon as
possible there's one more question who's
the Marty Carlin now we are still
looking for a Marty Carlin as as
that's yes they are big shoes to fill
but we are we are looking high and low
so before you you should all have a
presentation that looks like
this and now I'm on page two we're going
to be covering a broad range of topics
this
afternoon and you can see what they all
are and as I said earlier please feel
free to stop us at any time with any
questions I'm now on page three of the
presentation nhrs is was established in
1967 and is a contributory
multi-employer
defined benefit plan we provide
retirement disability and death benefits
as well as a post-retirement medical
subsidy to eligible members and
beneficiaries once members attain
eligibility they can receive a
guaranteed lifetime pension the pension
benefits are funded through through
employee and employeer contributions and
investment
income historically investment returns
have provided the majority of the
funding for those pension benefits and
this is typical of most public pension
plans the higher the funded ratio which
is something I'll talk about a bit later
the higher the portion of the benefits
that are provided by investment
Returns on the next
page nhrs is a component unit of state
government but is very different from
most other state agencies we are not
funded by the general fund we overseen
by a Board of Trustees the current
makeup on the board is shown on page
43 and in addition to the Board of
Trustees and the independent invest
committee both of those groups serve as
fiduciaries you the legislature are our
plan
sponsor nhrs staff implements the
statute rules and policies and in
addition to following New Hampshire
state law we also have to follow the
Internal Revenue code because we want to
maintain our status as a qualified
pension plan a lot of the words I'm
going to use are terms of Art and so
what a qualified pension plan is that's
a plan that the
members can make pre-tax contributions
into the monies in the plan earn
investment income but are only taxed to
those members when they begin to receive
a benefit or their beneficiary receives
a benefit and so we always want to make
sure that we're on the right side of the
Internal Revenue Service and maintain
our qualified plan
status also important is the New
Hampshire con institution especially
article
36a which protects our that that our
funds are for the exclusive purpose of
providing benefits and it requires the
board to certify employer rates by based
on sound Actuarial practice and it also
requires that the employers who
participate in our plan to pay the rates
that have been certified by the
board these constitutional Provisions
help ensure that nhrs remain on the path
to 100%
funding now on page
five the nhrs trustees have a fiduciary
obligation to ensure that the plan is
adequately funded the equation below
underlies and applies to all pension
plans the contributions plus the
investment income need to be in balance
with the benefit payments and the
expenses and this equation must balance
in the long term it relies on one of
Albert Einstein's most important
conclusions the compounding of interest
is the eighth wonder of the world and
that's what make pensions plans work the
contributions come in earn investment
income that compounds over time and by
the time members are ready to retire
they have there are sufficient assets to
pay their benefits as of June 30 2024 we
had 12.3 billion in
Investments as of the end of November we
had 12.6 billion in
Investments I'm now on page six this is
a graph that shows how our assets have
changed over time they continue to grow
and we are on a good
trajectory now now on page seven think
yes yes
please thank you this footnote here
November sorry note 2010 was the start
of 30-year amortization of unfunded
liability can you explain that just a
touch more for those of us who are
new gladly Madame chair members of the
committee um represent of Dees that's a
very important question and I we we'll
be coming back to that point at any
times during the
presentation the the main point is that
[Music]
in 8 9 10 11 we made a lot of changes to
the retirement system and we did
establish a 30-year recovery plan okay
okay but and and and I'll back up a
little bit more um as I said we we'll be
using lots of terms of art here unfunded
liability is an Actuarial term and it is
the difference between
the Actuarial acred liability what is
the present value of all of the benefits
that our members have earned and are
expected to be paid in the future and
the Actuarial value of assets the
Actuarial value of assets is different
from the fair market value of assets the
fair market value of assets which I just
mentioned it was
12.3 billion
on June 30
2024 um what actuaries like to do is
they like to smooth assets over a
fiveyear period so that no one good year
of performance or one bad year of
performance has a dramatic impact on the
condition of the
plan and so back as the chair noted
there was a significant unfunded
liability
in
um 2010 it was approx a little bit over
um5
billion and rather than try to pay that
all off at once which I think we all
know that the state of New Hampshire
doesn't have the assets to do that they
decide the legislature decided on a plan
to amortise that unfunded liability over
a 30-year
period editorial comment is that they
chose the longest possible period of
amortization and the method of
amortization that provided the lowest
initial cost as you would expect from
most of our other uh Financial plans but
we are playing we are paying it off oh
we are exactly and in 2017 when it was
decided that we needed to amortise any
additional unfunded liabilities that
were generated in 20 2017 or later those
liabilities those gains or losses
depending upon what happened that in
that period those will all be advertised
over a closed
20year amortization
period we learned a little does that
make sense as much as it can yes and
thank you okay there are two
te or
multiple could be
M Madam chair for the sake of folks at
home um show John how to run his
microphone forget
it I don't want to steal all of my
thunder but towards the end of the
conver the presentation there will be a
chart which explains the different tiers
of the
amortization
okay page seven um things have been very
busy
yes ju just to clarify the method of
amortization was issuance of bonds or
some other
vehicle um Madame chair members of the
committee
representative good luck
OHA um it is um being paid off through
essentially employer contributions and
when we have a discussion later on on
the employer contributions and how they
are calculated um you'll see
that yes it we did not Bond it where we
we basically took out a lean against
every employer which is which is the m
municipalities and the state
itself yes also to where your brains
going the Senate did attempt to bond it
and was told Federal by the IRS uh and
the federal government that we cannot do
that so there was an attempt
by um some members of the legislature
yeah by the um the senator out of
Manchester to look at actually
bonding that but we just can't do it so
it's not a
Avenue
okay so what we've been working at most
recently at nhrs is we've been doing a
huge pension application upgrade our
pension Gold version three we have made
updates to the to the Strategic asset
allocation plan we continue to take
cyber security very seriously and are
constantly enhancing and training our
employees we have we've continued to
enhance the education effort efforts for
our members employers and the general
public we now have a new five-year
strategic plan for the investment office
and we've also enhanced our efforts to
increase the number of members using my
account which is our online portal for
members when we now have over 30,000
users of on that
platform on page eight I will now turn
things briefly over to CFO Marie Mullen
to discuss to update you on some
initiatives in her
area thank you yes you don't really need
to read the charts because yeah there is
a literacy test to join the committee
okay and we just want to want you to
give us the highlights and your opinions
because that's a much more effective way
to present the data absolutely um we
wanted to provide an update in the
finance area because during the the
implementation some of you may have had
um requests from employers or heard
things about it so we wanted to kind of
update you on what we've done to address
some of the employer concerns some of
the areas that we um
identified um improvements that needed
to occur so this slide outlines some of
those um some of it was a structural
change internally where we um have now
assigned our employer reporting
specialist to a specific employer for
the city Town municipality school
district and they have one person to
deal with previously they could be
dealing with multiple folks um there
would be confusion repetition of of um
you know problems so we we've addressed
that and we so we've assigned one
individual person to work with them from
reporting to cash collection to
reconciliation of their accounts that
has received very good feedback um and
has been well received by the employers
um we also conducted listening sessions
to hear the problems that they were
having what what was missing what
reports did they need so we identified
some of that through the employer
sessions we have um produced
enhancements within the system we have
created new reports to assist the
employers so we wanted to provide that
information as well over the past year
we've done some of those things as well
um and we are looking at automating and
streamlining much of our processes
related to cash receipts um and then on
the finance like investment side we are
also looking at Automation and
transparency related to our investment
management fees and being able to break
those out more individually to the
manager and being able to see the the
performance from our managers based on
the fees um more proactively so these
are just some of the areas in in the
finance side that we've been improving
on we wanted to bring to the committee's
attention in case you are hearing
feedback from any of your
constituents and with that I'll turn it
back over to
Jen okay now on page nine um for many
years and HRS has been a tenant in
commercial real estate our current lease
expires in March of
2026 and we need to provide notice of
renewal or not to our landb Lord by May
of
2025 so we decided to take this as an
opportunity to see if there would be
another more coste effective space from
which we could house our staff and
provide member service so we followed a
very deliberate process um the board
chair appointed four members um to an ad
hoc real estate committee and five staff
members including the three of us um
were um selected to support their work
we worked with a broker kushman and
Wakefield to review lease and purch
options in central New
Hampshire and then after um we took a
total cost of occupancy approach and
considered the all the costs of renting
versus owning to make an informed
decision and after a comprehensive
review of the different options the
board approved us to enter into a
contract for purchase since then we've
engaged in a very thorough due diligence
we've done a site assessment building
condition and title search and no
material exceptions were
discovered page eight summarizes the
current situation um we're in at least
space in conquer over on 54 Regional
drive and our new premises will be just
north of here over in the Horseshoe Pond
um we're purchasing a threeory building
which as as you can tell has very easy
access to the um the different highways
that go through this area so it'll be
very convenient for our members it's a
32,000 square foot building the purchase
price is $5
million and we expect to close in March
and we've not yet determined a move
date page
11 um this walks you through some of the
significant developments since
2007 um as noted earlier in 2010 the
30-year amortization of the unfunded
liability begins that's what UA stands
for and what has impacted to a great
degree the unfunded liability is the
different changes we've had to our rate
of return you can see that happened in
2011 2016 and
2020 and for those of you who are
Finance people you know that when you
lower the discount rate the present
value becomes higher and so every time
we lowered our assumed rate of return
our unfunded liability
increased page
12 the next few pages outline different
benefit changes since 2020 and they
generally fall into two different
categories in ad hoc inflation
protection for retirees and
beneficiaries as well as the restoration
of group two benefits that were reduced
in 2011
so the change in 2020 um for the onetime
cola affected both group one and group
two further down on that page there was
a one-time temporary um salary temporary
supplemental allowance um for some
retirees and that affected group one and
group
two page
13 is was a change the first one from
2023 was a change
to um the group two benefits to restore
part of the benefits that were reduced
in
2011 and
then on lower down on that page um that
bill um augments um the benefit for
group one members have pushing by
pushing out the date at which the
benefit reduction takes place so it's
now aligned with the full retirement age
under Social Security before it had been
age
65 page 14 shows benefit changes that's
um from
2024 the one on this page is a new
benefit for eligible group two
members page 15 another um temporary
supplemental allowance um which benefits
both group one and group two members and
this this TSA temporary supplemental
allowance was paid in the months of
November and December to the eligible
retirees and
beneficiaries page 16 is more
legislation from
2024 this bill only affected group two
members and was also another attempt to
restore benefits that were reduced in
2011 as you can see there's been a large
volume of benefit related legislation in
the past few years and I doubt that this
year will be any
exception page 17 New Mexico I'm sorry
New Hampshire retirement system me
membership covers a broad range of
public employees throughout New
Hampshire we divide our members into two
groups one the first one is group one
which covers the employees and the
teachers so the employees that include
state employees City and
County employees as well group two are
the police and fire
employees we have 468 participating
employers um the single largest
exception to NH HRS membership is the
city of Manchester employees however we
do cover their teachers police and fire
employees page 18 shows you how many of
our members are in each of the group um
we have
um the the the employees and the
teachers are the group one police and
fire are group two so you can see for
yourselves how many members of the
different categories we have as well as
some other highlevel demographic
information page
19 um we Rec cross an important
threshold in fiscal year 2024 it was the
first year in which we paid $1 billion
dollar in pension benefits to our
retirees and
beneficiaries and over that same time we
paid close to 40 million in
post-retirement medical subsidy to the
eligible retirees and
beneficiaries and the reason why that
billion dollars is so important 80% of
our retirees and beneficiaries remain
here in New Hampshire and these payments
have a significant impact on the local
economies throughout New
Hampshire page 20 this is a graph so you
can see how much of the benefits go into
each of the different New Hampshire
counties page 21 is a description of the
different types of benefits we have we
have four different types of retirement
um there are different benefit
Provisions that apply to our group one
and our group two
members and there's also different
benefits Provisions that are applied
based on the vested stat is on the date
of hire we now have three tiers of
members as a result of the 2011
changes page
22 as you can see from the numbers on
this page NH HRS pays modest benefits to
our members you'll see that there's um
that the group two members have on
average have higher benefits but you
have to remember that our group two
members do do not participate in Social
Security and also note that our none of
our plans include automatic cost of
living
adjustments page 23 shows the
distribution of
benefits approximately 2third of our
members retire with a benefit that's
less than
$25,000 a year and very few only 2% have
a benefit that's greater than $755,000
per
year page 24 as wonderful as colas are
to retirees and beneficiaries they are
very expensive if they are not
preuner contributions in order to pay
them off over time
page 25 the member contributions are set
by Statute the employees in the
different groups pay different
contribution rates the employer
contributions are certified by the
trustees on a bial basis and the
timeline for this process is shown on
page
52 and this slide makes note of a
subsidy to local employers um
for um the contributions that they pay
there was one in 2022 and this year
there's also similar legislation that's
being
considered page 26 contributions and
funding every two years nhrs has our
actuary do a detailed Actuarial
valuation and they calculate the funding
status which is what's known as our
funded ratio that's the the metric that
many plans use to assess how well they
are doing on their funding what that is
it's the value of the Actuarial acred
liability liability divided by the
Actuarial value of assets so it tells
you how much how many cents per dollar
are on hand to pay each dollar of
benefits that will be paid in the
future and as a result of this valuation
that's used to um to set our employer
rates which have to be
sufficient and every four years we do an
experience study we just completed one
in fiscal year 2024 that covered the
prior four years and when the actuaries
do this what they do is they lift up um
the roof of the car the lid of the
the engine I'm not a car person um and
they look at every single assumption
that goes into
making the the liabilities they look at
how long are the members supposed to
live what how at what age are they going
to retire How likely is any one member
to terminate their benefit before
they're eligible for uh for terminate
employment before they're eligible for a
benefit um they look at mortality rates
they look at what's going on in the
economy what is do they expect for
future salary increases to be and then
one of the most important numbers is
what do they think our assumed rate of
return is going to be we were very
pleased with the
2023 experience study that they
recommended keeping our our annual rate
of return at
6.75% so that was a big relief to all of
us and I just want to also let you know
that this year we're in the process of
conducting an Actuarial
audit so what that means is is that we
have our regular actuary that has worked
with us for over 10 years we have
another actuary come in and essentially
look over their shoulder they review all
the calculations they've made they look
at every assumption that the actuaries
have made to see if they all are
reasonable and so it's like it's
basically getting a second opinion and
this is considered a best practice in
government government circles it's
recommended by the gfoa that pension
plant do this every five years and we
were due so we're having that done this
year
gfoa um the government Finance Officers
Association
page I'm on now on page 27 our employer
contributions are comprised of these
three components the normal cost that is
directly related to how much what
percent of an employee salary do we have
to withhold to pay their benefit in the
future then there's the unfunded
liability which is the big gorilla in
the
room and then there's also the medical
subsidy which is a closed benefit and
it's funded on a pay as youo
rate page
28 this chart shows what percent of each
of these components are in the
contribution as you can see the
overwhelming majority of the employer
contribution goes towards amortising the
unfunded
liability and you can see that ranges
from anywhere between between
77.3% and
84.2% depending upon which employee
group we're talking
about and this chart also notes that the
member the member share of the normal
cost which they all pay in contributions
the Actuarial convention is that all of
the members contribution rate is
allocated to the normal cost of their
benefit may I bring you back for a
moment uh the medical subsidy does the
term close close to benefit mean this
will
end yes it does it's for a finite group
of
people repres PE Madam chair
uh so for for
clarification as an example under the
slide you're on 28 normal cost looking
at specifically group two because of
their lack of social security
requirements um that the cities and
towns don't have to pay into
so if I'm reading this right you're
saying that the normal normal cost of
operation if we had no unfunded
liability for police would be 5.8 and
fire would be
6.1% is that was is that fair to say if
we had no pension debt at all that's
what it would cost to
operate group two um that's what it
would cost to pay the employer share of
the normal cost the um the member
contribution rates are on
on page
25 yeah and so you would have to add the
member share plus the employer share to
get to arrive at the total normal cost
do you have a do you have a normal cost
for the
employer that is the normal cost
employer this is that the far left hand
column the the 58 and the 610 yes okay
so that's the
employer normal cost okay so what what
social security refresh my memory is
6.75% I think you've transposed the
digits I believe it's 7.65 and that also
includes Medicare 7.65 is what a
municipality would pay in Social
Security responsibility to the federal
government for for that so with that
being said then what what I'm reading
here and what you're saying is it's
cheaper to operate this system than if
they were simply just on Social Security
for group two yes because in the P this
pension system the employers are paying
2third or so of the cost whereas with
Social Security it's only about
half I don't think that's what this says
that's what I'm trying to that's what
I'm trying to get out no I mean the the
member share of the normal cost is
between 66 and
74% of the total normal cost of
providing the pension so they're paying
for example I'll use employees because
the numbers are are
simpler the employee pays 7% the
employer contributes
2.4% that's right off the table can you
can you highlight that for me because I
I'm missing I'm missing what that is
okay the normal cost is what it would do
to the pension if we had no debt right
are you on page 28 slide 28 right
and the for an employee it's
2.42% from the employer and by Statute
the employee pay
7% That's for group one for group one
for group two the I don't know it's 11
or 12% roughly 1155 and 118 yep thank
you and the employer contribution is
about is slightly more than half that
it's 5.8 and 6.1 so the employer
employee are paying the greatest share
of their basic pension so so what I what
I was asking you um director
is because group two the employees that
are group two the municipalities are not
contributing to Social Security that
they're not that's not a liability they
have to meet the operation of group
two the normal cost is less than simply
just paying Social Security that's
that's what I'm trying to confirm here
absolutely yes that's corre yes okay
right because that's important to
to um to understand with the differences
between group one and group two as to
why group two exists it's a it's a
financial benefit for the municipalities
because they don't because of the wi
Federal windfall act they don't have to
pay in that 7.65% liability to the
federal government they can simply just
operate under the normal costs you have
listed to make that system work
yes and for the benefit of new employee
new
members we in once we start paying down
the liability so that the that is not
dominating the employer
contributions we
require the
employee contribution to go down so that
it never exceeds the total employer
contribution right um that's a safeguard
to prevent this municipalities from not
paying yeah and anyway that's well
that's to make it fair because right now
the employees are paying a large part of
their retirement because
of bad decisions that were made in the
990s that
um and so they're paying more than they
ought to just for their pension and so
are the employers the employers are
paying a bigger share right now but that
in only
15 years or so the employees will catch
up and they'll the employer rates will
come down and and they'll be starting to
pulla
bra thank you thank you madam
chair page 29 this chair this chart
compares the employer rates for fiscal
years 2425 as well as FY
2627 because of strong investment
performance in recent years years we
were able once again to reduce the
employer contribution rates for the next
bium which many towns and school
districts have reported with
Glee
good page
30 as discussed earlier both the board
and our independent invest committee are
fiduciaries and are responsible for
oversight of different areas
the board is approves the investment
policy including asset allocation and
set the Actuarial rate of return and the
board hires the investment consultant in
contrast the
iic um was created by the legislature in
2009 and the iic recommends investment
policy to the board and the the iic is
responsible for hiring and firing
investment managers based on advice from
the investment staff as well as our
investment consultant and the iic also
prepares annually a comprehensive annual
investment report which then gets
approved by the board and I will now
turn things over to Ral LEC our CIO to
walk you through information on our
[Music]
investments thank you good afternoon
everyone uh on slide 31 you'll see um an
ass allocation of what's listed on on
our uh website and one thing that's um
that you'll notice that's consistent
with our discussion is really a move to
make more increased transparency across
the the plan uh we regularly meet with
all of our investment managers every
quarter and more so as needed to
determine if they're maintaining
Fidelity to their investment um mandate
that we were hired we hired them for we
take a long-term approach uh 25 years is
Horizon some typically are 15 to 20
years the 25 years is this ensures that
we are thinking about the long-term
outcomes uh for the pension plan and for
the beneficiaries and
retirees we ma manage risk and liquidity
that's something that we always are
thinking about and we try to and we
strive to have a diversified portfolio
to be able to achieve the investment
income that that is meaning the benefit
payments that Jan that ex executive
director mentioned earlier uh what you
see in a pie chart is a representa a
representation of our Target where we
want to be and what the actual
allocation is obviously this is dated
this is as of the last fiscal year um
but the numbers are very
similar could I ask what the alternative
Investments are yes
um uh Madam chair uh represent
representatives of the committee uh
representative uh lean Leon
Leon uh the Investments that we make in
alternatives are are Diversified across
private Equity private
credit real
estate uh today um this new ass
allocation I'll will go through uh that
we made an update to uh last year uh
incorporates uh infrastructure which is
a new asset class for the portfol for
the portfolio so the uh alternative
would be all the major items private
Equity private credit real estate and
we'll include infrastructure in in the
near
future and I see sorry thank you I see
real estate's also a separate one within
here as well yes uh real estate
allocation the reason why it's broken
out is because we hire an advisor to
manage the real estate portion of our
portfolio that's towns and group and so
it's what it's considered a manager but
they have full discretion on the
Investments there um that does not um
that goes through the iic and Board of
Trustees uh but it's not does not come
through the investment team thank you
I'll save the rest for later I spent too
much time on Wall Street to not have
more questions okay but so that means
that the alternative investments in the
chart are the infrastructure private
credit and uh private Equity that's
correct thank you and so we'll we are um
Madam chair we are moving to a more
um a category that captures all the
private investments in one section
what's depicted here is how we um manage
the
assets
okay thank you
that's ah representative power thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh I was wondering if you could
break down the non- US Equity a little
bit non us Equity uh in the portfolio is
really
uh that's going to be combined right now
it just means um Investments managers
that we've hired to manage assets
outside the US those managers tend to
also allocate to the us as well so our
in our new as allocation we're moving to
a global Equity structure where we can
acknowledge that managers that do invest
in the US and and non- us can exist in
the same
portfolio um and that that allocation is
around
16% um today and we'll be around the
same amount um in the New York Global
Equity structure so you're saying that
the non- USX Equity also includes Global
equity which includes some us yes
typically the managers uh when they they
non us um typically have some
investments in the US and so we want to
reflect that better in in the portfolio
by uh stating it as Global Equity
whereas you have ability to do us non us
it sounds like this chart is MI mixing
your
investment managers with the actual
Investments yeah when you look through
it mam share to answer your question
when you look through you you'll see we
decompose it so that we can get better
transparency as to what's happening
there the managers do have that mandate
and that's typical for a lot of other
plans and managers that they do have an
the ability to invest in the US uh some
and others have ability to invest in
emerging markets and so you can some
people do break it out as us developed
and emerging uh this is just a structure
that we've historically used U that
we're are endeavoring to make more
transparent
repres would it be fair to describe the
various categories in the pie chart as
uh strategies rather than assets and
then their portion being an
asset allocated to that strategy um so
that your target assets are are those
goals uh or those uh the amount of
dollars that are invested in each
strategy and and are is the actual
representative of the assets within each
of those
strategies U Madam chair rep uh members
of um U committee um
representative uh sloi
SL guess is
good uh to answer your question is you
had a number of questions in there so
the ultimate allocation is really
looking to deor to give us the EXP
exposure that we're looking for which is
non us exposure or exposure to
Investments outside the US uh so that is
the Target that we're looking at and
that's the Strategic ass allocation that
you'll see referring to in in the in the
in the subsequent slides here the
managers that we hire and you're correct
in and saying that they are strategies
and so they go for either growth
strategy or value strategy uh or um or
um small cap or large cap and that you
know typically represents the larger
companies in economy or smaller
companies in the economy so they all are
within this this pie chart that we try
to employ and we try to structure that
in a diversified manner to be able to uh
to um spread out the risk to not be
concentrated in any one area or another
so you're absolutely right that these
are strategies that we try to employ but
this is a very crude way of trying to
capture that because it doesn't really
detail that but on our website we do
have uh the ability you have the ability
today to go through and look at okay
private Equity or private credit and see
the managers that are in there to be
able to denote the strategies and even
bucket what strategies are they are they
grow are they buyout growth capital and
and so forth and so
onch are these charts act the actual
distribution I don't know what the word
strategy
means I I when I looked at this
initially I thought this is how our how
our assets are how your assets asss our
assets are divided now you've introduced
this word strategy and I don't know what
that means Madam chair representatives
of the committee just just go the so yes
that what you're not seeing here is the
strategies that that so you're seeing
just the top level which is how we um
allocate the Investments between us or
domestic Equity non- us Equity fixed
income and so beneath that there are
individual strategies for each one of
those that are part of how we've always
invested I I think after the general
presentation we'll let let the uh
economists go off on a separate uh
separate side meeting sounds like a
subcommittee representative dery yeah um
roughly what percent of your assets are
in cash or liquid Investments that's
they're kind of buried in each one of
these categories but would you say you
have AAR large amount of cash or a small
amount of cash or can you comment on
that Madam chair representatives of the
committee uh representative dery uh yes
so in this Char we don't do not cash
where we try to keep cash as low as
possible our Target allocation for cash
is is 0% uh but we keep cash on
liquidity for Capital calls so it varies
between 1 and 2% historically and so
that's the amount of cash that we keep
but we we try to keep the target zero so
we try to keep the the money invested
followup followup so do you rely on the
investment adviser to decide like
suppose someone is thinking that there's
going to be a market correction and they
say let's dump some stocks and sorry put
it into cash and then buy again later or
do you just say let's just own stuff and
write it
out that's a great question uh what we
typically do is we work with our
investment consultant to understand
what's happening in the macroeconomic
environment so for in in this case of
when we had uh the covid and the mark
and the market tanked dramatically a lot
of uh portfolios a lot of people didn't
have an opportunity to sell uh a lot of
assets were distressed and and were
impaired so what happened is that
pattern came back and it it went back up
and so you'll see a sharp rise in
performance in for 2020 and 2021 so we
typically work with our investment
advisor we work with the committee and
the team does the work to be able to
assess what should we do to protect uh
the assets at the if if there's
something happening in the macroeconomic
environment um for the most part it's a
it's a long-term decision it's not a
short-term decision and so we really are
very deliberate and thoughtful about
what do we want to do in those
particular scenarios but we do
incorporate the the work that we need to
do uh we do um discuss that with the
with the board and with the iic and and
secure their advice and make a
thoughtful recommendation for
action and the contributions from
employers come in regularly throughout
the year and the pension payments are
regular throughout the year so that
balances a lot of the
cash what I what I can say Madam chair
is that it we are long-term investors
and so we we are projecting for the 25y
year Horizon so there there is
volatility in the market and we're
always conscious of that but we really
strive to make thoughtful decisions to
generate the outcomes in the 25e period
in
perpetuity the next slide on on slide
32 uh details our investment returns for
the 1 three five 10 and 25 year periods
uh what you'll notice that the returns
are very strong across those time
Horizons across volatility in the market
uh has has been a bumpy ride uh for the
last 10 15 years uh but we are uh
focused on um the assumed rate of return
which is six and 3/4 and all of these
are net of fee returns so we are
regenerating fees I generate returns net
of fees and that's what
matters the next slide on slide 33 uh is
a Time series of our rated returns and
so the intuition here for this slide is
the blue bars that are above the line
and so the other goal of having a
diverse portfolio is to strive for
consistency in returns and outcomes and
so it's not a you're not going to win
all the time uh there are issues in 2012
2015 and 16 if you remember back then uh
in 2012 we had the de sealing debate uh
the US um s PO is downgraded our
treasury debt from AAA to Able a and so
that uh was a a time of of turmoil in
the market uh Greece and and Spain were
going through issues and at that time
Greece was going to be um was close to
leaving the EU so that is the reason
there uh other 2014 2015 are low yield
environments and if remember that there
were negative rates uh in in the in um
for Germany and swiss deposits uh slow
down in global growth and so there are
periods where it's it's been very
volatile but overall the consistency and
and the shape of this is that the the
the the fiveyear smoothing is above the
line which is what we're striving to do
is really generate strong positive
outcomes next slide on slide 34 just uh
looks at some of the performance uh that
uh relative to our peers as we look at
other plans and how they're allocated
and happy to report that that
performance is very strong uh during 15E
period investment made decisions they we
out the the IC performed 8 84% of the
peers that we measure ourselves and this
data comes from our consultant Kalen our
investment consultant who is our general
consultant for the plan um and uh the
the the peers are all large uh public
funds uh and Define benefit plans so
quite strong uh
performance last uh last slide I'll walk
you through is slide 35 and some of the
work since I've joined the plan in 20
two years ago um Maria um our Chief
Financial offer service has spoken about
is improving the transparency and that's
something that's very very important uh
we are disclosing more information now
and nhrs has historically disclosed a
lot of information about the plan the
Investments and so we're continuing to
do that even more uh we want to also be
able to see the fees that the managers
are charging and so we want to be able
to to see what those are and disclose
that we also want a benchmark ourselves
against other plans and and make that uh
information
available um our executive director
talked about the Strategic asset
allocation that we just updated and so
we proposed the the addition of uh
infrastructure and private credit and so
those are two strategies We Believe will
be accretive to uh uh the portfolio
going forward it also allows us to
reduce the risk uh um overall we'll
still have exposure to to Global Equity
but we want to move uh assets from uh
Global Equity into infrastructure and
private credit which we think we believe
will generate strong
outcomes uh I ALS I we also developed a
fiveyear strategic plan for the
investment office that calls for the
recruit Rec uh recruiting and retention
of investment Talent which is incredibly
important for the work that we do um
investing in systems to be able to do
the analysis that's also something
that's going to be very important for us
to do is to is to make that investment
uh and also um transparency is the last
bit bit I've already talked about and so
we have already adopted um disclosing
our proxy voting summary on our website
the materials for all the meetings are
on our website uh and also a dashboard
that can disclose uh all of the
Investments that we've that we've made
is also available on the website and it
will be there every quarter going
forward so we're very proud of those
those um of that action we'll continue
to do more of that going
forward and with that I yield back to
our executive
director thank you very much Mr LC I'm
now on page 36 of the presentation the
Actuarial rate of return is one of the
most consequential decisions that the
board makes this R ratio rate is used to
calculate the unfunded liability and
effects the employer contribution rate
and let me just tell you a little bit
about how we arrive at this rate our our
actuary makes a recommendation to the
board based on a survey that the actuary
has done of investment Consultants to
determine the expected rates of returns
for the different asset classes that
nhrs owns and then based on the weight
of that asset class we come up with a
weighted average for what the
overall assumed rate of return should be
for the entire
portfolio and this is looked at every
year briefly when the actuary does the
valuation and is given a very thorough
examination every four years as part of
the experience study and as I noted
earlier the most recent experien study
did not result in any recommended change
to the assumed rate of return this chart
shows how what
our assumed rate of return has been
those are the green numbers you can see
back in 2004 we were at 9% so that was
coming out of the Roaring 90ss um and
over time that has slid down to
6.75% and you can see from the early
years from 2004 through 2010 our returns
were more aggressive than those of most
other public pension plans and since
then we've been a aiming at more on the
conservative side conservative yet
realistic um it's very difficult to
compare the two rates of returns of any
two pension plans because it all depends
depends on the what the plan's
underlying assets are so if two plans
have different asset allocations they
will have different assumed rates of
return page
37 as we mentioned earlier um 2024 was
um another busy session with 14 bills
introduced and three that were enacted
into law one was a um a temporary
supplemental allowance there was the
violent acts the disability benefit and
there was also a change in the group two
multiplier page 38 this slide summarizes
nhs's role Visa the legislature um we
are here to provide data and objective
analysis we do that through a variety of
media one is the fiscal note worksheets
the bill briefs that we prepare
afternoons like this afternoon when we
provide testimony or education and we
also to provide you with a great deal of
informational material our annual
comprehensive financial report the
actuary evaluations and the
comprehensive annual investment
report page 39 to summarize everything
that we've covered this afternoon NRA
nhrs does provide a modest pension
benefit we have a plan in place to pay
down the unfunded
liability and I'll have more detail for
you on that in two slides
and the board has taken many responsible
steps to assure proper plan
funding page 40 is a comparison of our
funded ratio relative to that of our
peers as I mentioned earlier the funded
ratio is the Actuarial value of assets
that's the fiveyear smooth assets
divided by the Actuarial acred liability
which is the present value of all of the
liabilities that our members have earned
the road to 100% funding is rarely
smooth but we are on the right path and
continue to make good
progress and it you can see by looking
at this chart every time that we
decreased our Actuarial rate of return
the funded ratio decreased and the
unfunded liability increased so you can
see that in years um
2010 2015 and 2019
page
41 this is the projection of where our
actuaries expect us to be over the next
years um on paying down the amortization
of our unfunded
liability so the green the apple green
line reflects the unfunded liability at
different times in the future today it
is 5.6 billion million dollar the
individual bars on the bar chart are are
comprised of the initial unfunded
liability from 2010 that's what the teal
is and then the other gains and losses
that are being amortised over 20-year
periods that were incurred after
2017 as you can see some of these
periods have gains such as 2021 and the
changes arising from the 23 experience
study and those are below the line and
those positive gains reduce the overall
unfunded liability but you can see that
we are very much on the path to
amortising our unfunded liability there
is a plan in place and we continue to
make progress on
it yes and
the accumulated liability
from uh pre 2011 is still the biggest
part of our deficit yes Madam chair it
is but it is
decreasing because we are at the point
now that we have paid off enough that
each before we
were in a place that the interest on the
unfunded liability each year was so high
that our unfunded liability kept
increasing but now we have turned the
corner and the unfunded liability is now
decreas increasing each
year page 42 I my apologies to those of
you on the committee who've seen this
chart before but I think it's a great
story New Hampshire is not the only
state that's working on reducing its
unfunded liability our neighbor to the
East Maine began their efforts on this
important Endeavor back in
1997 as a very good comparison as our
plans as you can see have many
characteristics in common similar part
participants number of active members
and retirees and interestingly both
states have similar constitutional
Provisions um what's especially
heartening is that you can see that
Maine when they started this in 1996
their funded ratio was
51% whereas when we started in fy10 it
was
57.4% in Maine now is at
86.3% and we're at 68%
so they got a good head start on us but
we're making good
progress page 43 um is the last page of
the summary um New Hampshire is very
fortunate to have strong constitutional
and statutory protections to protect our
financial future of the retirement
system and as you saw from the prior
chart this is a marathon it's not a
Sprint and there are no shortcuts it's
steady
progress and we are determined to stay
at the
course at that point I'd be happy to
answer any
questions I'm sorry we have some
appendices with different background
information if you'd
like yes and we
have um I think it's four pension
related bills this year so far there's
still more coming uh we'll be hearing
one next week that's the
um U unemployment compensation limit and
the others will be the week after
next Howard thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question I
wanted to uh look at the appendix uh
page 48 uh looking at active members
versus uh
beneficiaries so since 2015 it looks
like the active membership has not
really changed uh at all versus uh 2015
the active beneficiaries has increased
by like
15,000 uh do you have any concerns as to
being able to fund things in the future
uh as we're not necessarily seeing any
change in our active membership thank
you um Madam chair members of the
committee representative Howard um this
is very normal for a pension plan and uh
we do regular cash flow projections
going out many years um our actuaries do
this every year and we foresee no future
problems with
this thank
you yes and unfortunately our or
fortunately the retirees are living
longer than they we originally thought
they would so there's we keep
accumulating retirees
yes Madam chair I'll jump in since we're
all gonna you know sit in silence here
um your
predecessor and I have went a couple of
rounds because in the investment report
the detailed one that came out we we
were investing in
categories that were not yielding for
4%
and and we were doing this continuously
with a target of 6 and 3/4 or
realistically more like
seven
um with you now taking the helm are we
is the and I say we as a member of the
New Hampshire retirement system
um looking at getting out of those
investment categories that seem to never
ever make the Ben
Benchmark and I understand you know I I
I appreciate the word diversity in
Investments okay I I don't really hold I
think a lot of that is a cop out
um there's you know the the system seems
to have a Target right I mean you guys
have this is where we got to be and when
you're invested in things that never
ever ever make the
target why would you do that so with you
taking the helm in that regard now I'm
just curious as to your philosophy is to
is to um diversification of investment
into things that never make the
target Madam chair members of the
committee and representative
Pearson I think I got that right maybe
um working on it um it's it's a great
question so so the one of the reasons
the philosophy around having um
Investments that may not yield the
target is that is for diversification so
when and and that is it's not a
satisfactory answer but it's it's it's
one of the reasons why you would have
investments in a portfolio that may not
yield because not everything's going to
be up at the same time and so if you're
taking a 25y year Horizon you're going
to have things that are going to be up
or down at different times and that's
why you want the pockets of investments
in different places and so the answer
for nhrs is that there are investments
that um that have been made that may not
have worked out in the past for example
energy if you if we had a lot of energy
in our portfolio and in the time that
you saw in the 200 uh uh 145 energy was
taking a big bath and so those
Investments may not have panned out as
we expected and so then you look at the
returns you you see that there are some
you know it didn't make the target of 10
to 12% or low teens or even high single
digits and and low teens and so those
Investments tend to be in private uh
markets and will eventually come out of
the portfolio after 10 12 years and so
what we're doing now is to put in
Investments that will generate a high
yield and so I talked about
infrastructure and so our infrastructure
approach is to do infrastructure that's
going to be a cash yielding investment
so it's low risk core infrastructure not
value adding opportunistic we're not
building new data centers but we are
invested in in assets that are going to
have a higher yield Road and today
environment the yield you know yields
are are high and back in 10 10 years ago
maybe five to 10 years ago yields were
very low and so by the nature of being
in the market you're going to invest in
in assets that are not going to generate
a high yield and so what investors
typically do is they invest they use
leverage and My Philosophy is I I don't
like to use leverage um I don't believe
that it's needed um and I think that
adds another dimension of risk that that
is not appropriate for a plant of our
size but I do want to diversify amongst
um equities bonds credit infrastructure
real estate I think those are the way to
build a diversified portfolio and there
are going to be times where invest there
are yields that are going to be that're
not going to make the hurdle but when
you put the whole thing together it
should be Diversified and it should
yield the the target of six and 3/4 or
at least better than that because we're
not just trying to get that number we
want to get that number plus the skill
that we're applying to by hiring the
managers with skill by doing the work in
the investment and investment um
allocations and working with the
committee to do that so it's not just
the six and three quars we want to try
to do better than that to be able to to
be able to pay out the benef the
benefits I don't know I hope that
satisfies your answers your question oh
you answered the satisfaction part we'll
get to so how long do you sit in a
category that doesn't even make the 6
and 3/4 before you cut it loose and say
you know what we're just we're just not
going to invest
in whatever you know Monopoly apartment
buildings right you know there's got to
be a point where you just go look this
is just not it's not making a grade here
so and it seemed like your predecessor
didn't have any idea what what that
would even look like so I'm just
wondering what your philosophy is on on
categories that have for 25 years have
failed
Madam chair members of the uh committee
yeah we can be informal now we're pass
the the basic presentation yeah so so My
Philosophy it depends on the investment
so for public market Investments we have
a 30-day termination clause and so and
it's not just looking at the performance
and so if it hasn't performed in 25
years and you're still investing in it
that's not
like that's not good um and I and I
don't know any investor who would do it
for that long and and defend it but we
typically look at Short medium and
long-term performance which is 1 three
and fiveyear periods we also look at how
the asset class has let say for example
if you're at small caps small cap stocks
have not been doing well in the last
couple years it's been very tough for
them um however the managers that we do
have when we do invest in small cap our
managers who are picking the stocks are
doing active management I think that's
the term that I want to use as active
managers and they able to make the
decision to be uh in one category or the
other even though the sector is as a
whole is not doing well and so you want
to be with those managers and we we we
feel we have very strong small capat
managers but I don't want to wait long
to be able to recommend a termination
now that's for U Public Market invest U
Investments and and that third da Clause
is for those for private markets you're
typically invested for a draw down fund
for 10 plus whatever extensions they
they're they're contracted to do so
typically two extension two oneyear
extensions so you could be in in a in a
fund for about 12 years maybe longer and
so those Investments you can't really
just terminate because if you if you
decide to sell it you may sell it at um
and you may you're going to take a
haircut on selling it and so you don't
want to do that so in those cases you
want to weigh out okay am I going to get
at least my money back um I I'm I'm
happy to say that we don't have
Investments that are in that category
the Investments that my predat servicer
has invested in has has done well so
that performance is performance that
that were generated by on his track
record and and I feel that those are
really good now some of them may not
have done as well but we're continuing
that same consistency to be able to
invest in Investments that are going to
continue to do well so for those private
Investments it's tougher to get out of
them um but you want to ensure that if
if you're not going to be able to get
your money back you take some kind of
action and so that's part of the
monitoring the the risk management and
making decisions and recommending
decisions to the board uh and the ISC
for
Action as a
philosophy representative Lam thank you
I have a question which probably I
should ask first ask the question of the
chair um since I'm the chair of the
pension subcommittee and there seems to
be a lot of interest of us getting into
some of these details should do you
think that it would make sense for us to
dig into asking more about these asset
classes and the investment strategy in a
subcommittee meeting on pension or
should I go ahead with my next question
I think that would be very appropriate
because there are some members who are
not not as interested in the details as
others okay uh and also anyone on the
committee can show up to the
subcommittee and participate and also we
have no
say there's a separation absolutely true
a separation a legal separation between
the pension system and the legislature
all we can do is bring our concerns to
them and in fact I was going to comment
to the Board of Trustees that if you've
got a 25-year investment Horizon keeping
25% in fixed assets seems awfully
high so but that's a decision for the
Board of Trustees not for
us all right any general questions all
right thank you very much for coming our
uh oh just oh just a quickie yeah uh I
do like the chart on page 41 uh looking
forward uh in time into paying down the
UA I'm curious is there a similar chart
for the historical to see that we're on
Trend uh it would be nice just to to
have that
information um so you would like to see
this chart since the beginning of 2010
is that what you would
like where wherever it is that we
decided to assume assume the the debt of
unfunded liability uh to today uh
Looking Backward around 10 would be the
right data yes we'll get that for you
thank you appreciate it yes and uh there
will be like I said there will be a
subcommittee on pensions they will be
undoubtedly dealing with the bills we
have and they'd love to uh Grill you
about your investment strategy and so
forth represent have one more thing
something that I would have liked to
have seen um you started giving us
historical context around 2007 but I
think the 1990s needs to always be in
the conversation as to how we ended up
in the problem that we're in and the
role that this legislature
pay in making that problem happen a
substantial one so I I would I would
like to see that in perpetuity be in
there so we understand our
responsibility to this crisis and it's
not mismanagement by the New Hampshire
retirement system that led to this it's
the it's the fault of the legislature so
um having that in there I think would be
beneficial yes yes in the early 90s the
legislature mandated the retirement
system take on an an unrealistic
Actuarial formula so for 15 20 years
everybody thought they were overfunded
and therefore diverted a large number a
large amount of the investment returns
into funds that were not the basic
retirement fund
so uh we got ourselves into a lot of
trouble that way and also too we gave a
reprieve to the cities and towns for a
number of years oh that was why we we
did it we wanted to cut taxes yeah so
that I that historical context of that I
think is valuable yes there in a few
years there won't be very many of us who
even remember the stories about it
well Madam chair we have a separate
presentation entitled nhrs past present
and future which goes through all of
that history it will not be forgot if
you could uh at least send that to us
I'm sure that will be very informative
to a lot of people all right I think we
will break now and thank you for coming
we uh we'll undoubtedly see at least
some of you when we get to the pension
bills thank you again for the
opportunity oh
thank you for answering the
question
e
e e